you are about to master the core
fundamentals of docker
by building a node express app with a
[ __ ]
and redis database sanjeev teaches this
course
he starts at the absolute beginning and
then takes you through a full production
workflow
what's going on guys so in this video
i'm going to show you guys how we can
set up a workflow
for developing node.js and express apps
within a docker container
so the first thing that i want to do is
i want to set up a quick and simple
express app that we can use
for demonstration purposes and the
reason why i didn't actually prepare the
the express app ahead of time is first
of all this is going to be the quickest
and simplest of apps we'll be able to
knock it out within like a minute
but i want you guys to focus on these
steps that we need to actually
create this app because they're kind of
important because we're going to
recreate those steps within the docker
container as well
so i've got my project directory i
called it node docker already here
and i've got it opened up in vs code so
you know with any other express app the
first thing that we have to do
is get our package.json file so i'm
going to do an npm init
and that's going to create our
package.json and since we are creating
an express app we're going to have to
install
express i'm going to do an npm install
express
so now we've got our dependency uh the
next thing that i want to do is also
focus on the fact that we did
uh create our node modules folder so
that happened when we installed express
and the final thing that we need to do
is actually create the rx application
so i'm going to create an index.js file
and i'm going to import our express
we'll do const express
require express
and then we can do const app equals
express
right then i'm going to specify the port
that i want my express server to live on
so
i'm going to do const port so this
variable is going to represent the port
that it's going to be listening on
and i'm going to set it equal to
process.env.port
pipe 3000 right so if you don't know
what this line is it's basically saying
that if the environment variable called
port has been set
we're going to set this variable to that
value however if it's not set we're
going to default to a value of 3000.
usually common configuration and then we
can do an app.listen
and we'll listen on that port
and when our server comes up we can say
console.log
listening on port and then we'll pass in
that variable
all right so now the last thing that i
want to do is set up a quick route for
testing purposes
so i'm going to do app.get
and we'll just say the root root path
and then we'll do
rec res
and so if anyone sends a get request to
this path
uh we're just going to send back a
simple response
which is going to be uh we'll just send
an h2
that says hi there
and i forgot the comma right here all
right and so that's our entire express
app
uh i'm going to start this app real
quick
we're going to do uh node and then
index.js
and it looks like i forgot to save
probably
all right so it looks like i already had
another express app listening on
port 3000 so i deleted that so now if we
do a node index.js it should start it's
going to be listening on port 3000
we can go to our web browser real quick
and we can just go to local host
colon 3000 and when we do that we should
see it say hi there i'll zoom in for you
guys so that you can see that
and so that confirms our express app
works so we've got our dummy express app
so now we can go ahead and get started
with
actually integrating our express app
into a docker container and setting up
a workflow so that we can move to
developing our application exclusively
within the docker container
instead of developing it on our local
machine like we just did
so now that we got our express
application complete or the demo express
application
uh let's work on setting up our docker
container now for this video i'm going
to assume that you already have docker
installed on your local machine
if you don't go ahead and do that now
just follow the instructions on their
website
it's fairly straightforward just make
sure you follow the directions for your
respective operating system
but once you have docker installed on
your machine head on over to
hub.docker.com and i want you to just
search for
node within that search bar right there
once that's finished loading you'll see
that the first result is the official
node docker image so this is a public
image provided by the node team
and it's a fairly lightweight image that
basically has node already installed for
us
so that we don't have to do this
ourselves and if you take a look at the
documentation you'll see that we've got
all of the various different versions
that it supports so you can get
version 15 version 14 all the way back
down to
version 10 if you really want and it's
got directions for this
image or any specific things that are
relevant to this image when you want to
deploy a container from it
now this docker image right here is not
going to have everything that we
ultimately need for our application
because the whole idea behind docker and
an image is that the image is going to
have
every single thing that's needed for
your application to work
and so for our application we obviously
need to get our source code into the
image
and we also need to get all of our
dependencies like express and the other
dependencies that our
application may need
so to do that what we're going to do is
we're going to create our own custom
image
and we're going to base this custom
image off of this node image so we're
going to take this node image
we're going to copy all of our source
code into that node image
and then we're going to install all of
our dependencies like express
and then that final image is going to
have everything that we need to
ultimately run our application
so let's get started on doing that now
okay so let's get started on creating
our own custom image
to create a custom image we need to
create a docker file
so the docker file is just going to be a
set of instructions that docker's going
to run
to create our very own customized image
so let's create a new file
and we're going to call this docker file
with a capital d
now in our docker file it's going to
have a set of commands
that docker is going to run to create
our own personalized image
and the first command that we always
have to do is we have to specify a base
image
so when you create a custom image what
you're ultimately doing is you take a
base image or a known image of some sort
doesn't matter where the image from
it can come from your own uh docker
repository it can come from docker hub
it can come from anywhere you just need
a image that docker has access to
and we're just going to tweak it a
little bit so that uh it contains all of
our source code
it contains all of our dependencies and
things like that so in this case
you know we already found our um our
base image it's going to be this node
image because
that's really the only thing that we
need to run right we just need it to
have node
and anything else to run node so we're
going to take this as our base image
and the instructions here is going to
show you how we can ultimately use that
so
here you just specify node and then you
can do colon and then the specific
version you want if you don't specify
the version
i forget what version it grabs but if
you read the instructions it's probably
going to say
it grabs like version 14 or something
like that or maybe the latest version
right so what we do is we do from and
we'll capitalize from
and then we say node because that's the
name of that uh image or our base image
and then we can do colon and then the
version we want so i'm going to specify
version 15
not that we need version 15 we can run
14 or really any version we're not
doing anything specific to any new
versions i just want to show you guys
how to actually specify a version
uh so that's something that's absolutely
needed the next
command is technically optional but it's
still recommended and that's called the
work dur command and i'm going to set
that to slash app
so what this command does is it sets our
working directory of our container
to be the slash app directory within the
container
so i know this slash app directory
exists in the container because i've run
the node image and i know it's got a
slash app directory
but setting the work directory is really
helpful because anytime you run a
command
when you set the work directory it's
going to run that command from this
directory
so we can put all of our application
code in slash app
and we can run node index.js on slash
app
and it's going to run it automatically
in slash app without us having to
specify
uh so the working directory just uh is
the directory where you run
all your commands and it's also the
directory where if you copy any files to
your container
it's going to by default send it to this
directory so this is just recommended
but it's not
technically necessary now the next thing
we want to do is
uh we want to copy our package.json file
which is this file which contains all of
our dependencies and anything else that
we need
and we're going to copy it into our
docker image so let's go to
um so we can run the copy command and so
we copy the path to the package.json
file which is our current directory
so we just do package dot json
and then we have to specify the
directory we want to copy it to
in our image and so i'm going to do
this dot which means the current
directory and the reason why i do that
is because we set our working directory
up here to be slash app
so when you do dot it's going to assume
the slash app directory we could
technically also just do slash app
same result but since we have the
working directory set we can just
specify it relevant relative
to that directory
uh the next thing is once we have our
package.json remember it's got a list of
all of our dependencies we want to
actually install our dependencies so we
want to run an npm install
so in our docker file to run a command
we can do run
and we can do npm install right so
we now have our package.json file copied
over and then we run npm install now
we've got express installed for us
the next thing we want to do is and this
part's going to be a little bit
confusing
but we're going to copy the rest of our
files so all of our source code
everything else
into our docker image so we'll do a copy
again
and here instead of specifying a
specific file
i'm going to say the current directory
so it's going to grab every single file
every single folder
within our current directory and we're
going to copy it to
just like we did here where we just did
a dot which is going to send to the
slash app we're going to do the same
thing so we can just do dot
or dot slash same thing and right here
you might be a little confused
you might be wondering well why do we
copy the package.json first
and then copy all of the files over do
we even need this step
before if we're going to copy all of our
files this should
copy our package.json and it does the
reason why i split it up into two
different steps is a little bit of an
optimization technique
so let me explain how docker images
actually work when you create an image
from a docker file it takes each one of
these steps and it
it treats it as a layer of the image so
you could think of an image as just
basically these five steps or five
layers so once you build all five layers
you have the ultimate image or the final
image
so this first command creates one layer
of the image
this second command creates another
layer of the image
this third command creates the third
layer the fourth layer and the fifth
layer and they all kind of build on top
of each other
and what's important is that after each
layer the docker
docker actually caches the result of
each layer
and what i mean by that is when we run
uh docker build when we actually build
our image for the first time
what's gonna happen is that it's gonna
run this first step and it's gonna cache
the result so it's gonna say
hey look we uh downloaded the node image
from docker hub and then we cache that
result right we then set the working
directory to slash app and we cache the
result of that
we then copy package.json we cop we
cache the result
we then npm install cache that result
and then we copy all of our code and we
cache that result
and this is important because let's say
we decide to uh
rebuild the image again right if nothing
changes
docker is efficient it knows that
nothing's changed in any of these layers
and it just takes the final cache result
of step five which is the last layer
and it just gives that to you so if you
run docker build which is the command to
actually create the image
the first time you run it it's going to
take a long time because it's got to run
all of these steps
and especially the npm install if you
have a lot of dependencies it's going to
take quite a while
but the second time you run it if
nothing's changed you'll see it'll be
done in less than a second
and that's because it's cached all the
results and the reason this is important
and the reason why i split this up into
two different steps is i want you to
think about
what happens during our development
process right when we are
actively working on our code what
changes our package.json does not change
very often
right i mean we do occasionally add new
dependencies that's normal but it's
for the most part your source code
changes but your package.json and your
dependencies don't change very
frequently
and so by splitting this up into two
different steps what happens is
we cache each of these layers right
and so we're going to cache uh the node
image we're going to cache the working
directory
and in reality those two will never
change right
we're never really gonna change those
two so uh we're always going to
essentially catch the result from step
two and onwards
but the thing about docker is if any
layer changes
right say that layer three changes and
what i mean by layer three changes is
that
if package.json ultimately changes uh
where maybe we add a new dependency
we have to rerun step three and all of
the steps after that because we don't
know how that's going to impact step
four
we don't know how it's gonna impact step
five and so by caching
by splitting these up into two different
steps we can say that listen if
package.json never changes
then we're going to cache that result
and since realistically when we're
actually programming package.json is
just not going to change so we're going
to cache that result
and since package.json is cached then
we're going to also cache the result of
npm install
because nothing's really changing so we
cache those results and so when we
change any of our source code
within our application the only step
that really changes
is layer five where we copy the rest of
our code
and so we only need to rerun step five
however if we didn't have
this split up into two different steps
where we have a copy package.json and
then copying the rest of our files
uh what would happen is that anytime we
changed our source code
technically it would rerun everything
including the npm install
because it doesn't know that we only
changed our source code
it just sees that listen this step where
we copy all of our files has changed
we're going to have to rerun all of the
steps after that so by doing this
we know that package.json will always be
the same so we can cache the result of
these two steps and only make
and only run step five which is the
changing of our source code so it's a
little bit of optimization
if it didn't make sense i don't think i
did that great of a job of explaining it
but i'll show you guys this when we
actually build our containers how it
actually
caches the results of each step and how
it's a little bit of an optimization to
actually do this and split this up into
two different steps
all right so the next thing that we want
to do is uh we know our application is
going to be listening on port 3000
so let's do um expose so we're going to
say our container is going to expose
port 3000 and then finally
when we start our container we want to
tell it what command to run
right and since this is a node
application and our entry point into our
node application
is this index.js we have to tell it to
run
index.js so we do cmd
brackets and we're going to do node
and then index.js all right so when we
deploy our container
it's going to run in index.js so this is
at runtime
and this is at build time so hopefully
you guys understand this so this is when
we're building the image
this is the command that's going to be
assigned to the container when we
actually run the container
and so that's all we really need we're
going to go ahead and actually create
our image now so let's
go to our terminal down here and i'm
going to stop our express server because
remember
we're no longer going to be developing
on our local machine we'll be developing
on the docker container so make sure you
stop
your local instance of your application
all right and let's build our docker
container oh sorry our docker image
we're building the image right now not
the container itself
so we'll do a docker build
and then we're going to specify uh the
path to our docker file it's actually
called the context it's not necessarily
the path of the file
um it has a little bit more of a meaning
to it with but i don't want to spend too
much time going i just think about it
as the path to the docker file so this
docker file is in the current directory
so we're just going to do a dot
so let's run that and i realized i
forgot to save my file so let's save
that
i'm going to rerun that and i want you
to pay attention to the output
notice what's happened and i think this
is kind of important when you're trying
to understand what's happening
uh you could see that on step one of
five it says we're going to grab
uh the node image from docker diode io
so it's pulling the image
from the uh from docker hub right and as
i said
each one of these is a separate step or
a separate layer right if we go down
we go to step two and it says working
directory is set to slash app
you can see that it says cached so
you're not going to see it say cached on
your machine that's because i ran this
as practice before i recorded this video
but it's not going to say that it's
cached when you ultimately run this
so so keep that in mind but if you run
this again
if you run it again right what should
happen is that it should cache all of
the results right and so now
all the ways down to step five it's
cached so if you run it again like i
said there's an optimization
where it actually caches the results and
the second time you run it it's going to
be much much faster
so now what we're going to do is we're
going to do a docker image ls
and you can see the new image it created
this is the one without a name because
we didn't specify a name you also see
the node image that it pulled from
docker hub
which is node 15. now i don't like the
fact that we didn't give this a name
so let's do a docker image rm this is
going to delete the image that we just
created
i'm going to pass in that image id
and if we do a docker image ls you can
see that it's gone now
so now we're going to go back to the
docker build command that we ran but
this time we're going to pass in a
specific flag
so we'll pass in the dash t flag so here
we can give it a name i'm going to call
this node
dash app dash image
all right so once that's complete we'll
do a docker image ls
and now you can see we've got our image
that we just created
so now that we have our image let's go
ahead and run it and let's test it out
see if everything works
so we'll do a docker run
and we'll do node dash app
image so here we're just specifying the
image that we want to create a container
from which is
this image that we just created but
before you hit enter there's a couple of
flags that we got to pass so first of
all
i want to give my docker container a
name so that i have some kind of way to
identify it so we can pass in the dash
dash name option and we'll call this
node app
so keep in mind that last uh the last
entry in my command is the name of the
image that we're creating a container
from
this is the name of the container that
we're creating
and then finally there's one more flag i
want to pass which is dash d so that
means it's going to run detach mode
because by default when you create a
docker container from docker run
you're going to be attached to the the
cli or the console or whatever it's
called
but here i can run in detach mode so
that my command line's still free and
open
so let's hit enter and it looks like it
successfully created my container
um i can do a docker ps and we should
see that there's a container open
at the moment
all right so let's test this out and
what i'm going to do is let's just go to
my local host colon 3000 hit refresh and
let's see what happens
all right so it doesn't look good it's
spinning which most likely means there's
something broken and it looks like there
is
don't worry guys i know exactly what's
wrong i perfectly did this
so let's tackle exactly what's wrong
with our docker container in the next
section
so we were unable to connect to our
docker container on localhost
colon 3000 now why exactly were we
unable to do that
well let's take a look at our docker
file and if we go back here
uh we can see that uh we do have this
command expose
3000 and i think naturally most of us
would assume hey look we're exposing
port 3000 so we should be able to access
that well not exactly this
line does absolutely nothing this is
really more for documentation purposes
if you delete this command
and create a brand new image it will not
impact our image or container
at all in any way shape or form it's
just so that when you share your docker
file with someone else they'll know
hey look this image expects you to open
up
port 3000 for everything to work so this
line doesn't actually open up port 3000
and the thing about docker containers is
by default
they can talk to the outside world so if
a docker container wants to reach out to
the internet
or wants to reach out to any other
devices in your host network
uh it can do that however outside
devices like the internet
or your host machine or any other
machine from the outside world by
default cannot talk to a doc
container this is almost like a built-in
security mechanism
right you don't want the outside world
to be able to access your docker
container but your docker container can
outside can access them so how do we
make it so that the outside world can
talk to our docker container
and keep in mind when i say outside
world i don't just mean the internet i
also mean our local host machine
right and when i say local host machine
i mean my windows machine right here
right to actually uh talk to the
container
from my computer which is kind of seen
as like an outside device
we have to um poke a hole in our host
machine
uh and what i mean by that is that by
default right
our docker container nothing from the
outside wheel can talk to our docker
container
so we have to basically say on our host
machine hey if we receive traffic on a
specific port
we want to forward that traffic to our
docker container
and the way we do that is it's very easy
first of all let's kill our container
uh we don't need that anymore so i'm
going to do a docker rm
and then specify the name of our
container we'll so we'll do node dash
app
and then i'm going to pass in the dash f
flag so this is stands for force
so by default usually you have to stop a
container before you can delete it
if you pass the dash f flag it'll allow
you to delete a running container
all right so now if i do a docker ps we
should see an empty list
so let's do docker let's rerun that
command
but here i'm going to pass in another
another flag i'm going to pass in the
dash p flag
i'm going to specify uh this so let me
explain what this is
in a second so we've got port 3000
and then colon 3000 so what exactly does
this mean we've got two different
numbers
we've got the 3000 to the left of the
colon and 3000 to the right of the colon
so the number to the right let's start
off with this one
is the um basically the port that we're
going to send traffic to on our
container
and our container remember our
application is listening on port 3000
so we want to send this to port 3000
right
if this was set to 2000 then we would
want to set this to 2000 so whatever our
container is expecting traffic on
the number to the right of the colon
should be set to that value now the
number to the left
represents um it represents traffic
that's going to be
uh basically coming in from the outside
world so if another device on your
network
uh or even your local host machine right
my windows machine
if we send traffic to local host port
3000
right we're going to take traffic that's
coming in on port 3000 and sending it to
port 3000 on our container
but in this case even though the two
numbers are the same they don't have to
be so let's say
we wanted to basically poke a hole so
that anybody that sends traffic to our
windows host machine here on port 4000
we should then forward it to our docker
container in that case we would change
this to a 4000
and we keep this to port 3000 because
remember it's still listening on port
3000.
however if this was 2 000 then we would
change
um this number to be 2000 here
right so hopefully that makes sense i've
set up a little quick diagram
i don't know if you guys understood it
at this point but hopefully the diagram
makes it a little bit easier to
understand so let me pull that up
so here in this diagram i've got my host
machine right which is this big blue box
which is my windows machine
and then i've got this node container in
green right here
and so what's going to happen is you
know we've got those two numbers right
basically what we want to do is when our
host machine right our windows machine
receives traffic on port 3000
what we want to do is we want to take
that and forward it to port 3000 on our
node container
so that's why we have 3000 colon 3000 so
the first 3000 represents the red arrow
and then the second 3000 represents the
yellow arrow
and this also applies when we send
traffic from our host machine
to the local host ip so to ourselves so
if we send a
traffic to local host port 3000 it's
going to take that traffic
and it's going to forward it to port
3000 and once again like i said before
we don't have to do three thousand to
three thousand we could change this to
uh four thousand and then we would send
traffic to local host four thousand
and it would forward it to traffic on
port 3000 on our node container
because once again our node container is
listening on port
3000 because that's what our express
server is listening on
all right so hopefully that made sense
i'm going to run my container now
so i'll hit enter and i changed
everything back to 3000 column 3000
because
uh that's just a little bit simpler why
not have both of those numbers match
there's no need to unnecessarily
complicate things
let's do a docker ps all right
and you'll see that we've got our
container but we under this port section
you can see that it looks a little
different you can see that
right here we've got basically 0.0.0.0
on port 3000 with an arrow to 3000 slash
tcp so what this is saying is
any traffic destined to your host
machine uh
for uh you know my windows machine right
here on port 3000
is going to get forward to port 3000 on
my container so now
let's go back to their web page and
let's do a refresh
and you can see now it says hi there so
we have successfully
sent a request to our docker container
on port 3000.
before proceeding any further i do want
to show you one thing real quick let's
actually
uh log into our docker container and
take a look at the files in there
so we can do that by typing in docker
exec
on it for interactive mode and then
we'll specify the name of our docker
container which is node
app and then we want to pass in a new
command instead of the usual node
index.js
we're going to passion bash so this is
going to allow us to take a look at the
file system of our container
uh so here by default it's going to drop
us in the slash app directory just
because
uh we set the working directory to be
that uh and here i just want to type in
ls so this is going to list all the
files in that directory and so you're
going to see all the files that are
copied over so we've got our
package.json we've got the package.lock
we've got the node modules folder our
index.js
and we've got the docker file
and you know the reason why i wanted to
show you the file system is
you may be wondering what is our docker
file ultimately doing in our docker
container
right our docker file is there to create
an image but we don't actually need it
in our docker container
and i also wanted to point out one more
thing if you take a look at this copy
command right here
what it does is it copies everything in
our current directory so every single
file
and it copies it into our container or
our image
and this is a bad thing because
there are going to be files that you
don't actually want copied into your
container
right just like our docker file that i
mentioned we may also have an
environment file that has a lot of our
secrets
that we don't actually want copied into
our container potentially
also on top of that we don't need to
copy our node modules folder
this is actually a waste of time because
a lot of times this folder is actually
fairly large
and we don't need to do that because
remember we're copying our package.json
file and then we're doing an npm install
so there is zero reason to ever have to
copy this node modules folder
into our container
and on top of that we ultimately want to
move away from developing on our local
machine so
moving forward we won't even have a node
modules folder on our local machine
it'll only ever exist
within our docker container so why are
we even copying it in the first place
uh it could be stale we may not even
have it so
um we need to find a way to make it so
that docker does not copy
over files that we don't ultimately want
copied over just like this docker file
just like the node modules folder if we
have git configured we definitely don't
want that copied over
uh and so we can do that by creating a
docker ignore file
right and that probably sounds a little
familiar because if you work with git
kit has a git ignore file
for files that you don't want checked
into your git repository
same exact concept so let me exit out of
my container
so we can do exit to exit out of the
file system and
uh i'm going to kill that in that
container so we'll do docker rm
node app and then we'll do dash f for
force
and let's create a docker ignore file so
i'll do a new file
and i'm going to call this dot or period
and then docker
ignore
and within our docker ignore file we're
going to list out every single file
and folder that we don't ever want
copied into our docker container
so the first thing is we don't want to
copy our node modules folder because
we're going to do an npm install from
our package.json anyways there's really
no need to ever copy it over
we don't want to copy over our docker
file
now that we have a docker ignore file
there's really no need to copy that into
our docker container
uh and then a few other things right if
you have git you don't want to copy git
you don't want to copy your
git ignore uh for now i think that's
good um
you'll see later on in the video we'll
add a couple more files but for now
that's okay
just do a save and now let's rebuild our
image
so let's find that build command so
docker build dash t
the name and then uh the path to the
docker
file so that's their current directory
so i'll run that
and just make sure i didn't change
anything in my index.js
if everything looks good so let's run
that
all right so that's done let's run our
container from the new docker image that
we just created
so if we hit up for that docker run
command let's see if i can find it here
we go so docker run
dash piece we're going to open up port
3000 run in detached mode
we're going to give the container a name
of node app and we're going to use the
node app image that we just created
all right so we did that let me just
quickly double check to make sure i
didn't break anything
so hit refresh it looks like
everything's working perfect
now let's go into our docker container
again so we can
run that uh exec command and let's just
make sure it didn't copy over any
unnecessary files
so let's do an ls and now it's perfect
right
we no longer see a docker file there's
no docker ignore file
i can't verify for you guys that we
didn't copy over the node modules folder
but
just trust me this node modules folder
is from running a uh
an npm install on the fourth step and
not because we copied it over from our
local machine
all right so let's exit out of that
okay so now that we got our application
working in a docker container and we can
access it from our local machine
uh let's see what happens when we change
our code i'm gonna go back
to my uh my index.js file
and i'm going to just tweak something
right here it says we're sending an h
that says hi there
i'm just going to add a couple of
exclamation points we'll save that
and i'm going to minimize this and let's
hit refresh let's see what happens
we hit refresh nothing happens we don't
see the exclamation points so for some
reason
our code didn't get updated and i want
you to think about
why that is it's actually a really
simple answer
right uh basically what happens is first
of all
we have to take our docker file we have
to build an image so we built an image
and then we built a container from it
now we changed our code
to add the exclamation points but our
image that we created from our docker
file
was run before we made these changes so
the code in that image
does not have the exclamation points and
so basically our image has a stale
version of our code
which means our container which is
running from that image has a stale
version of our code
and we can prove that if we do a docker
exec and go into our code
if i do an ls we can see our index.js
file
and i do a cat which is just going to
print the contents of that file if i do
an index.js
you can see that there's no exclamation
point so it's running a stale version of
the code
so how do we actually update that well
it's actually very simple
first of all make sure you change save
all your changes
and now what we're going to do is we're
going to rebuild that image
well first of all let's delete our
container we don't need it anymore and
let's rebuild the image
so where's that build command so build
right so now if you take a look uh
you'll see that um because our source
code changed it had to run step five
once again
uh so now if we do a docker image ls
this new image
which we named it is the same name as we
had before
now has the new exclamation points built
into the image
so if we deploy this image with a docker
run command
it's the same exact docker run command
hit enter
and now if we go back to our
our web browser hit refresh we can now
see the exclamation points
so that explains why um our code didn't
automatically get updated
however i'm sure you're thinking well
this is kind of a strenuous process
uh for when you update your code right
every time i make a change i don't want
to have to
uh rebuild an image and redeploy a
container that's a very slow process
that's going to slow down your
development time
uh and what i'm going to do is i'm going
to show you guys how we can work around
that because
that's obviously not um sustainable you
can't be rebuilding an image
and re-running a container every time
you make one tiny uh change
in your code so what we're going to do
is we're going to make use of something
uh called we're going to make use of
volumes so within docker we have
volumes which allows us to have
persistent data in our containers
but there's a very specific type of
volume called a bind mount
in docker and this is a special this is
special volume because
what it allows us to do is allows us to
sync a folder
in our local host machine on our in my
windows machine in this case
it allows me to sync a folder or a file
system
to a folder within our docker container
so what i can do is i can take all of
these files
and sync them into the slash app
directory of our container
so that we don't have to continuously
rebuild the image and redeploy a
container
every time we make a change it'll
automatically sync those two for us
to really speed up the development
process so let me show you guys how we
can do that
so we're going to delete our container
and what i'm going to do is we don't
need to rebuild our image the image is
just fine
but i'm going to hit up a few times so
we can get to this run command so we're
going to use the same exact run command
and we're going to pass in a new flag it
doesn't matter where you put it
and it's going to be the dash v flag so
this stands for a volume
there's a couple of different volumes or
different types of volumes but remember
we're using the bind mount which is a
special volume
that allows you allows you to sync a
folder from your local machine
to a folder in your docker container
uh and so the syntax for this is you do
dash v
and then you specify um
the local folder or the path to the
folder on your local machine so i'll
just say
path to folder on local machine
on local and then we do colon and then
we do path
to folder on container okay
so kind of like pseudo code just uh so
you guys understand so this is going to
be the location of
this folder right because this is the
folder that has all my source code and i
want to sync that
to a folder within our docker container
and that's going to be in the slash app
directory because that's where we're
going to store all of our source code
so let's hard code those values uh and
so here unfortunately
i can't just do a dot right here um it's
not going to register that it's not
going to work you have to actually pass
in the whole path
so if you're using vs code like i am you
can
right click here and then just select
copy path
and then you can right click and it's
going to grab the entire path
in my host machine to this folder
obviously i'm going to delete the docker
file section we just need to get into
the node docker
which is the name of the folder that
houses all of my code
and then we do call in and then we do
the path to the folder in the
container so what folder do we want to
copy it to easy we want to copy it to
slash app
right and that's so that's all you have
to do you hit enter and it's going to
sync your code however
i do want to show you a couple of
shortcuts because that does look a
little messy having to type all of this
out
and so what we can do is we can make use
of um variables
and so i'm going to delete this i'm
going to show you guys what you can do
instead instead of having to type out
that whole nonsense
and it's going to be different based off
your operating system
so if you're using windows and you're
using the command shell
then what we can do is we can type in
percent
cd percent so that's going to grab the
current working directory
so that way i don't have to copy that
entire path and that only works on
windows command
shell if you're using windows powershell
then you're going to have to type in
dollar curly braces pwd closing curly
braces
that's going to grab the current working
directory
and if you're on a mac or a linux then
you can type in dollar
parentheses pwd uh and then close
parentheses
so that's just a shortcut or you could
type out the entire path whatever is
easiest for you
feel free to do that so i'm just going
to use
my percent cd
percent
all right and so let's hit enter
and uh you know depending on you know
what uh operating system using if you're
using windows
anytime you're doing file sharing um you
might get this warning there's a couple
of optimizations that you can make
i usually just ignore it for now all
right so
now theoretically it should be syncing
this entire folder
with the slash app directory in our
container
uh and so uh let's minimize this
and let me just refresh this so you can
see right now we've got the
four exclamation points
let's go back to our code and i'm going
to delete the exclamation points
all right and then after we delete it
let's save it and let's see
if i refresh this page does the changes
take effect so let's hit refresh
and it looks like it didn't so do you
guys know why it didn't take effect
well let's take a look right because
theoretically this command
uh this flag right here should sync the
folder so we should see uh
this file gets synced to our container
so let's drop into our container
and take a look at what the file looks
like in the container to see if it
actually updated
all right because maybe i was lying to
you guys and this does absolutely
nothing and i wasted your time
so we log in let's do an ls so we've got
our index.js and let's print out the
contents of the file by typing in cat
and then index.js and if we take a look
at that we can see that hey look
it did actually sync our code it deleted
the four exclamation points
so why exactly did we not see the update
in our web browser
well this is easy for anyone that's ever
worked with express applications i'm
sure you might have an idea as to what
exactly
caused this problem remember
anytime we make changes to code in any
node or express application
we have to restart the node process we
did not restart the node process we just
changed the code and we hoped that it
would automatically work
but we had to restart the node process
right and um you know we could go in we
can kill the node process start it again
but obviously that's inefficient right
we already have a solution that we
already know
is going to work and that is we're going
to make use of nodemon
right nodemon will always look at your
code and if any changes take place it's
going to restart the node process
so that the changes are updated in real
time so let's get that set up and
installed
i'm going to exit out here and we need
to update our package.json file so let's
get nodemod installed as a dev
dependency
and i'm going to do this on my local
machine just so that we can have it set
up in this file
so i'm going to do an npm install
nodemon
save dev so this is going to be a dev
dependency just because we don't need it
to run when we actually deploy to
production
and remember i'm just doing this on my
local machine right now just so that we
can update my package.json file
all right so we've got our dev
dependency
now let's go to my package well i'm
already in my package.json
but let's set up a few scripts
so we'll do a start and this will just
be the usual
node index.js
and then we'll have a dev which is going
to be
whoops which is going to be a nodemon
index.js so
by running nodemon in dev mode
it's going to automatically restart uh
index. it's going to restart the node
process anytime there's any changes to
our source code
now as a heads up when i was uh doing a
dry run of this demo
i did run into some issues on
specifically it looks like windows
machines so if you're on a windows
machine and for some reason
later on in this video uh you run into
some issues with nodemod not actually
restarting
you may need to pass in the dash l flag
uh so that
that kind of fixed most of the issues uh
if you do run into the issue just try
and
try the l flag uh if you want to read up
on it just
just google the error message that you
get or just google no not restarting on
windows for docker
and they'll give you an explanation for
why you need to pass in that flag but
i'm going to keep that in there because
i'm running a windows machine and i did
run into that issue
so let's save all of that and let's uh
let me kill the the docker container
that we have so i think there should be
one running so we'll do a docker rm
node app dash f
all right uh so now that we made changes
to our package.json we're gonna have to
rebuild our image now
to do a docker let me see if i have that
command cache someplace here we go build
so we'll do the docker build
and notice how it's taking a little bit
longer this time and that's because
our package.json file changed so it had
to rerun step three where we copy
package.json
and then rerun step four and then we run
step five because we have to run all the
steps after that because we don't know
if changes to this file change to any of
the cache results
so that's why it took a little bit
longer this time but hopefully by now
you guys get an understanding of how all
the caching works in docker
all right so now let's redeploy
actually before we redeploy there's a
couple of things that we have to change
i realize i forgot to do this
so um back in our docker file right
we're not going to run node index.js
anymore so
in the development mode we're actually
going to run
if you take a look at our package.json
we're going to run npm run dev
so we can run node mod so let's go back
to our docker file
we'll do npm
run and then
dev save that sorry about that guys
we're gonna have to rebuild our image
again
so let's uh rebuild it
all right uh and so now let's run a
container from that image
uh and this time we want to do it with
the bind mount again
let's hit enter we've got our docker
container
let's quickly test this out okay so the
exclamations are gone which is fine
and let's make a quick change to our
code i'm going to re-add the exclamation
points
save it all right and if i hit refresh
look at that so it looks like nodemon is
doing its job and anytime we make
changes to our code
it's automatically restarting the node
process and our bind mount is
successfully syncing the code from our
local machine
to our docker container
now i want to do a quick little test and
i'm going to do this because i suspect
depending on how you guys followed along
to this video so far
you may have run into an issue in the
most recent step
so let me delete my docker container so
let's do a docker rm node
app dash f
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
take this node modules folder on my
local machine
which i don't need anymore because we're
not developing on my local machine and
i'm just going to delete it
all right so now that it's gone i'm
going to redeploy the container
i'm going to show you that we're going
to break our application so if i
it's now running and if i go to
my web browser hit refresh you can see
it spins and it's eventually going to
crash
let's give it a second there you go so
what exactly happened well
let's take a look so if i do a docker ps
let's see if my container is running
and look that's the first issue why is
our docker container not even showing up
on this
well when you do a docker ps it's only
going to show you running containers so
let's do a docker
i think it's ps minus af yep so this is
going to show you all containers
started or stopped and you could see our
most recent container
our node app container and it said it
exited 30 seconds ago which means
usually if it automatically exit it
usually means something crashed
so if you want to take a look at the
logs to see why something crashed we can
always do a
docker logs and then you specify the
name of the container so it's going to
give you all the logs for that
and this is going to show us some node
or nodemon logs and you'll see right
here it says nodemon not
found so what exactly is happening we
know for a fact
that nodemon should be installed because
we had everything working before
the only change we made was we deleted
the local
node modules folder why should that
impact anything because it was working
before
well let me tell you what happened so
what happened was um you know we we
create our docker image
right where we copy our package.json
file and then we run an npm install
so at this point when we run mp install
it should install nodemon for us
and it is in there but then we copy
um all of our files which once again not
an issue actually
i don't know why i kind of made it seem
like it was but we copy all our files
all of our source code uh and then um
the command specified for the container
is npm run dev
now when we go back to our docker
command that we used to actually create
our container
we created a bind mount so the bind
mount
syncs this folder with the slash app
folder
and this is where the issue occurred
because it's syncing
this folder since there's no more node
modules folder in this folder
it syncs that with the slash app folder
so it ends up overwriting the slash app
folder
and deleting the node modules folder in
the slash app folder of our container
because it doesn't exist in our local
our local directory and since we have a
bind mount it's going to sync those two
directories together
that's the problem right because once we
deleted the node modules folder
from our local machine it will also
delete it from our docker container
and then without the node modules folder
that container has no idea what the hell
nodemon is
so how do we get around this issue how
do we prevent
our local directory our local folder
from overwriting the slash app directory
and deleting the node modules folder
well there's a simple little hack that
we can do and that is we're going to
create a new volume
and we're going to create a volume
that's called there's a couple different
volumes like i said
in docker a bind mounts one we also have
an anonymous volume
and volumes work based off of
specificity so we've got a volume
on our container for the slash app
directory but we want to make sure that
we preserve
the slash app slash node modules so we
want to make sure this bind mount
doesn't override the slash
node modules folder within the app
directory and the way we can do that is
we could just specify
another um another
uh volume so first of all let me delete
our broken container
all right and then we'll run that same
command but i'm going to pass in
another v flag for another volume and
i'm going to say this
volume which is going to be an anonymous
volume is going to be that for the slash
app
slash node underscore modules
this is a little hack that you can do to
prevent the bind mount from overwriting
the slash app slash node module folder
because all volumes in docker containers
are are based off of specificity so even
though
this bind mount should sync with the
slash app directory
we can see that we have another volume
that uh that references the slash app
slash node modules folder and you can
see that since this is a longer path
that's basically more specific so that's
going to prevent
this bind mount from deleting the node
module folder basically
this extra line is going to say hey
don't touch this folder
since it's a more specific more uh it's
a longer path it's more specific so
it overrides the bind mount the bind
will still sync all of the other files
it just cannot touch the node modules
folder
all right so now if we hit enter
let's do a docker ps and it should stay
running
let's just make sure it didn't crash and
it looks like it didn't
so now if we go to the website let's hit
refresh it's there
let's make a few changes just to make
sure nothing else broke
we'll delete the exclamation points hit
save
and then hit refresh and it looks like
everything's working
everything looks perfect so far now
there's one thing i do want to point out
so you'll notice that we do a copy where
we copy all of our files into our
container
uh at the build stage and you might be
wondering well do we really need to do
that
if we have our bind mount and the thing
is the answer is
yes because the bind mount is really
just for our development process
uh we only use the bind mount when we're
developing because that's when we're
changing our code
when we go to actually deploy in
production
there obviously isn't going to be a mind
mount because why are we changing our
code in production
uh so we do we still need this copy
command for when we deploy into
production because there is no bind
mount and we have to make sure all of
our source code
gets copied into the image for our
production container
all right guys so when it comes to
docker volumes and bind mods i want to
show you one last thing we're going to
make one slight change
it's not required but it's kind of best
practice so what i want to do is
i have a i have my container still
running if you don't go ahead and just
run this command again
where you have the bind mount and the
anonymous volume
and i want to drop into bash
so that we can take a look at the file
system so docker exec dash it
app and then bash
all right so we're in our container and
let's do an ls and so remember since we
have the bind mount
this directory is going to sync with the
directory in our container
however it's a two-way street so if i
make changes here it's going to get
updated here
right if i do a new file i'll just say
my file and i do an ls here
right we can see my file however if i
create a file within my container
it's going to add it to my local machine
as well so if you want to create a file
uh just for demonstration purposes you
can type in the command touch
it's going to create an empty file and
i'll just say test
file so if i do an ls we created our
test file
and you can see the file showed up on my
local machine i want you to think about
a potential issue with that why is
our docker container changing our our
files
do we ever need is there ever a scenario
where you want your docker container to
actually be making changes to your
source code
or any of the files associated with the
source code probably not right it seems
like almost like a security issue
for it to even allow it to do that right
there may be certain instances where
your application actually creates files
on the local machine and in that case
you might want to allow it but for the
most part
you don't want your docker container
being able to
touch any of your files or make any
changes to it because there's really no
need to
and so what we can do is uh we can take
our bind mount that we created
and we can make it a read-only bind
mount which means the docker container
will be able to read any of the files
but it can't touch any files and it
can't create any of the files right it's
read only
so let's get started on that we'll exit
out of here and i'm going to kill this
container
and to make this a read-only bind mount
it's very easy so let's run this command
uh where'd it go there we go
let's run this and all we have to do is
specify
uh colon at the end of slash app we do
colon
r o and that implies read only
so we'll hit enter hopefully it's
running
uh and uh we're gonna go and drop into
bash to our container
all right and so now here let's create a
file so we'll do touch
new file and look at that it says this
is a read-only file system it cannot
make any changes it cannot create any
new files it cannot edit any files
everything is read only so this is a
little bit of a
an enhancement that we can make so that
uh it protects our source code and it
doesn't allow our docker container to do
any kind of funny business
with any of our source code all right so
let's exit out of here
and i'm just gonna do a little cleanup i
don't need these files
all right and now what i want to do is
um i want to show you guys how we can
start making use of environment
variables within our docker container
so if you go back to our index.js file
and you remember our express app
the port is going to listen on is going
to be based off of an environment
variable called port that we pass in
uh if this variable is not set it's
going to default to a value of 3000. so
how do we make use of environment
variables
within docker containers first of all
let's go to our docker file
and we're going to specify a default
value for our part variable so
after our copy command it doesn't
technically matter where you put this
but we can say env so this is
referencing environment variables we're
going to create one called port
and we're going to say the default value
for this environment various port 3000
and then we want to expose remember this
is just merely for documentation
purposes this command doesn't really do
anything um
instead of having to hard code 3000 what
we can say is
we can reference this port variable by
passing in a dollar sign and the name of
the variable support
so if this gets updated this will
automatically get updated as well
so let's save that and what we want to
do is uh
let's see is do we have any containers
running yep so let's just kill that
all right and let's rebuild our image
because we made a change to our docker
file
and we can do a docker build for that
all right so now that those changes are
made
uh our application shouldn't really
fundamentally change because
now we're just setting our environment
variable to be port 3000
um before it was defaulting into a value
of 3000 but now since the environment
variable is set to 3000
everything should theoretically work the
same it's just now going through that
environment variable
but what i want to do is when we
actually deploy the container
we can specify what value we want that
environment variable to be set
because this is just the default value
we can always override it
so let's deploy a new container
with the same exact command with both of
our volumes
but we can pass in an environment
variable by passing in dash dash
env or you can just do a single dash and
the letter e
so whichever you prefer i don't know why
i prefer the double dash emv but
uh whatever you prefer uh and then you
pass in the name of the environment
variable
equals and then whatever value you want
to be set to so let's say we want our
express server
to listen on port 4000 now it's going to
change to 4000 however
before we hit enter and actually create
our container remember since our express
application is listening on 4000
we have to change uh the port that we're
sending traffic to because right now
we're sending traffic to our container
on port 3000
but our express app is listening on port
4000 so we have to change this to 4000
or then our application is going to
break
uh we don't need to change um the port
that we
uh have to hit on our local machine we
could technically change it to 4000 but
it doesn't really matter
uh you can pick any value really here
so let's hit enter
and let me just make sure it's running
all right so it's running
uh so now if i go to
the web browser hit refresh it looks
like it's working
just to double check everything's
working fine let's just make a few
changes
to add the exclamation points back save
hit refresh it looks like everything's
working uh just to double check
i do want to make sure that the
environment variable did get set
so we can drop back into that container
again like we always do
where's that command docker exec
so in a linux machine if you want to see
the environment variables you just type
in print
env and so here we can see that the
environment variable of port
equals 4000 was set and so that confirms
that when we ran
our docker run command and passed in the
dash dash env flag
we were successfully able to overwrite
the port variable or the port
environment variable
that was specified in our docker file
now when it comes to your application
you may have more than one environment
variable actually you most certainly
will
and if you have a lot of environment
variables uh you know we
you can pass in the dash dash env flag
as many times as you want
so if you wanted to you can say where
where'd it go here we go so if you
wanted to pass in another one you can
just do
env and then whatever that variable is
however if you've got like 10
20 environment variables that's kind of
a little bit of an exhausting process
and it's a little bit of a pain and so
what you can do instead is we can
actually create a file
that stores all of our environment
variables so here i'm going to call this
you can call whatever you want but
standard standard convention is dot env
and here we can just specify port equals
4000
right and so that's going to essentially
do the same thing in here you could just
provide a list of all of your
environment variables
and let's save that and i'm going to
kill my docker container real quick
and so now if you want to load uh
environment variables from a file
instead of having to pass
each one line by line uh let's go to
that docker run command and we can
remove the dash dash env
and we can pass in dash dash uh whoops
dash dash env
file and then the path to our
environment fireball so
from our local directory we do dot slash
and then
dot env and so that's going to grab this
environment variable file and then all
the environment variables stored in here
i think i saved it yep and let's hit
enter
hopefully this works let's go docker ps
alright it's running i'm going to log
into the container
and do a print nv let's just make sure
that it's set and it looks like it's set
so
those are the two different ways to
specify an environment variable and
to set environment variables for your
docker container so that your
application
can get the necessary data that it needs
now one thing i want to point out is uh
as you've been creating docker
containers and deleting them
if we do a uh docker ps uh you'll see
that we just have one container running
if you do a docker volume ls this is
gonna list all the volumes that you have
and you can see that we've kind of built
up a couple of different volumes and you
might be wondering
what are these from and why are they
building up as you keep creating
containers and deleting containers
they're going to slowly build up over
and over and you'll eventually end up
with hundreds
uh and the reason for that is if you
take a look at the command that we're
running for our docker container
this uh this volume that we specified
right here for the slash app slash node
modules hack
uh this is anonymous volume so every
time you delete your container it's
going to preserve uh that node modules
folder in here
and uh we don't actually need to
preserve it right because we're going to
be deleting
and creating new containers all the time
so uh you can go in and manually delete
the volumes
right you can always do a docker
volume rm and then specify the volume
name
or you can do a docker volume prune that
should remove all unnecessary volumes
but if you want to make sure that these
volumes don't build up usually what i
like to do is when you do the docker rm
command
um it's not going to delete the volumes
associated with that container
so if you want to delete the volumes
which in our case we do
there's obviously plenty of instances
where you don't want to delete the
volumes because the whole idea behind a
volume is that
it's persistent data you want to
preserve it so like if you have if you
have a postgres database or a sql
database
right uh you want to preserve uh all
your database records so you would never
want to delete that
but in our case we just have an
anonymous volume so that we can get
around that limitation that we ran into
before
so when you delete a container just pass
in the dash v flag
when you pass in the dash v flag it'll
make sure to delete the volume that's
associated with that container
so that it doesn't build up uh so for
now
i'm just gonna do a docker volume i
think prune should work
it's gonna say hit yes let's see if i do
a docker
volume ls uh you can see that it's
deleted all but one and this is the
volume that's associated with the
container still running so
if you want to do the docker that little
trick i just showed you
with the running container where is that
here we go dash fv
it's going to delete the container and
it's also going to delete
the volume as well so moving forward to
do the dash
f uh and then v so that you can delete
the volume as well
so now when it comes to um creating our
container we've kind of set up a nice
little quick workflow for
developing a node or express application
in a docker
container however the command to run the
docker
container this command right here is
kind of long
and you know i don't want to have to
rerun this command every single time i
want to get my container
up and running although i'm sure you're
thinking well you can just hit the up
arrow key so it's not a big deal
and that is 100 true however keep in
mind when you're actually developing
uh you know like an express application
or some kind of node application
you're probably going to have more than
one docker container right right now
we're just building the
uh the express server but in a
full-blown application you might have a
container for your
database you might have an elasticsearch
container you might have another
container for redus you're going to have
multiple containers
right and each one of those containers
you're going to have to run a command
that's this long
or potentially as long and at that point
it starts to become a real hassle of
getting your entire development
environment up and running and even
getting your production environment up
and running
because you're gonna have to run five or
six docker commands you have to make
sure there's no typos or anything like
that
so what i'm gonna show you guys is a way
we can kind of automate all of these
steps
so that we don't have to run this
monstrosity of command and we're gonna
use a feature called docker compose
where we can create a file that has all
the steps
and all of the configuration settings we
want for each docker container so we can
say like hey
i want to create a node container using
the image that i created
and i want to create a volume uh for the
bind mount and i want to create an
anonymous volume
i want to pass in the environment files
and i want to open up these ports so you
can pass in all these steps into a file
and then you can just run one very
simple command to bring up you know
as many containers as you want so if you
have like six or seven different
containers in your development
environment you can bring up all six or
seven all at once with one command
and bring them all down with one command
so let me show you guys how to do that
uh so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
create a docker compose file
and so we're going to do is we're going
to do a new file we're going to call
this
docker compose dot yml so that stands
for yaml
uh it's a certain type of syntax that
you use
so what we want to do is with your
docker compose file the first thing we
have to do is specify the version that
we're going to use
now if you go to this website right here
it's going to show you all the different
versions of docker compose and the
features that they support
now we're not gonna do anything crazy so
i'm just gonna use version three but
if there's a specific feature that you
need then you're gonna have to make sure
you grab the specific version this is
like a
this web page has a list of all the
features that each version supports so
you can just take a look at this page
and see what's the minimum version that
you need to actually run all the
specific
features that you want but i just
defaulted version three so we'll say
version
colon and then three
now the next thing we want to do is we
want to specify all of the containers
that we want to create
and so within our docker compose file
each container is referred to as a
service
so we do services
and then we just specify all of our
services now this is very important with
yaml files
uh spacing matters okay so uh we're
going under services and we're gonna
provide a list of all the different
services that we want so i want you to
hit tab
just once and then here we're going to
provide our
container our first container in our
example we just have one container which
is our node app
and we want to give this container a
specific name you can call it whatever
you want
we can say like oh my node app or
we can call this node project whatever
you want just give it a name
i'm going to call this node app because
that's what it is
and then colon and then we're going to
add in a specific
configuration settings for that
container uh so
because we're gonna do configurations
for that container i want you to hit one
tab
and then i want you to start adding in
the the different
um the different configuration settings
so the spacing matters unfortunately so
if i
if i start moving things around you know
it's going to break things so you want
to do one space
for each level and keep in mind if you
have multiple containers let's say you
have a postfish
container you would add a postgres
service if you had a redis
reader service you'd add one here so
this is how you add more containers or
more services
within a docker compose file we just
have one so i'm going to delete these
now under node app we have to specify
um a build setting so what image are we
going to use well
we have to build the current docker file
in our current directory so we can say
build right and then we pass in a path
to our
docker file so it's going to be our
current
our current directory or whatever
directory this docker compose file is
so this is just um automating the the
docker build command so that we don't
actually have to do it doc
compose will do it for us we just have
to pass in the path to the docker file
a couple other settings let me actually
just hit up
the up arrow keys to see all of the
different options that we have so
we do need to expose a port so let's
open up a port so we can pass in the
ports option
so under ports one tab remember
and here we can provide a list of ports
we want to open so for our container
we've only been opening up one port
but theoretically you can open as many
ports as you want
so you do a dash because it's going to
be a list of ports
and then here we're just going to do
3000 colon 3000 you already know what
that means i'm not going to rehash that
if you wanted to add another port or
open up another port you can do that so
you can do like 4000
colon 4000 as well but we're just going
to open up one port so i'll delete that
now i'm going to hit backspace again so
we're lined up with built-in ports
because once again we're still under the
node app service
and here we want to pass in all of our
volumes so we'll do
a volumes
and we're going to pass in our two
volumes and once again this is going to
be a list so i want you to hit tab
just once and then we're going to pass
in a dash so the dash signifies a list
so the first one is going to be um our
um
our bind mount and the great part about
this is that when you use a docker
compose file we can just do the dot
syntax we don't need to use this
variables that i mentioned before so we
just do dot slash
colon and then slash app
and i think you can pass an ro if you
want if you want to be read only i don't
really care
right and then we need to pass in our
anonymous volume right which is uh this
one right here and that's that little
hack that we did to make sure that we
didn't override our node modules folder
so we'll do slash app slash node
underscore
modules
and then last but not least i'm going to
add my
environment variable it doesn't really
matter where you put it so
once again line it up with build ports
and volume so we do environment
and we say dash and then here you
provide a list of environment variables
so we can do port equals 3 000.
all right keep in mind in this case this
would be like the equivalent of
running um the
environment variables one at a time uh
so let me see if i can find an example
so like this
however we can pass in a file like we
did down here
if you want so that we can use the dot
env file and the way to do that would be
let me see you can go down here we can
say uh
env underscore file colon
and then we can say dash you can provide
a list of files
and then the path to the dot env file so
whichever syntax you prefer i'm just
going to comment this out
i'm just going to use this because we
just have one environment variable so
there's no need to
import it in from an environment
variable file
all right so let's hit save this has all
of the settings
that we need for our uh node app service
uh and once again you know if you're
building a full-blown project you're
gonna have multiple services so you're
gonna see
how this kind of really simplifies the
entire process of getting your entire
development set up
uh and up and running and as well as
tearing it down all within one command
so make sure you save that
and what we want to do is we're going to
run the command docker compose
so we do docker dash compose this is
important right don't do
docker space compose it's a different
command we want docker dash compose
and we want up so that's going to bring
up everything that's in our compose file
and then one important flag is if we do
help let's see what options we have
we do have a d flag right if you
remember when we run our containers
we have to pass in the slash d flag or
then we'll automatically attach to our
containers
which we generally don't want so we can
pass in the same thing for our docker
compose
so we can do docker compose up dash d
so let's see if that works
uh so first thing you're seeing is that
it's actually building our image
and so it's running uh oop looks like i
ran into wait
up that's just a warning don't worry
about that
i think that's a yeah new patch so
that's just a vulnerability message
don't worry about that
uh so it built our image if we do a
docker image ls
you'll see that this is the image that i
built
uh and notice the naming convention what
it does is it grabs the
project directory which i called node
docker and then it passes underscore
and then node slash app so the note
slash app is from the service name
so it took the project folder did
underscore and then the service name if
we had one for postgres it'd be
underscore postgres or whatever we
called it
all right so it built the image and then
it also started our container so if we
do a docker ps
right you can now see that we have one
container running and it called it once
again
take a look at the name node docker
which is the project name
underscore uh then the name of the
service and then there's an underscore
one
i think if you have multiple if you spin
up multiple node app services i think it
goes like one two and three i think
that's why the one gets appended
um but let's test this out let's just
see if everything works um so going back
here if i hit refresh
looks like it works and uh let's change
our code
and delete the exclamation points just
to make sure it updates
hopefully it works and it looks it looks
like that guys everything works
perfectly so hopefully you guys can see
how easy it is now
to actually bring up our entire docker
environment which is one simple command
and bringing it up is just as easy as
bringing it down so now if you want to
tear down everything
we can do uh let's see we just do docker
dash compose
instead of up i'm sure you can guess
what the command is it's just down
and just like when it comes to deleting
docker containers
by default it will not delete those uh
anonymous volumes so if you want to
delete the anonymous volumes
with the docker compose down we can do a
dash v and that's going to delete
all the unnecessary volumes that it
creates so do dash v
and you can see it's stopping the docker
container it's then removing it
technically when you run docker compose
it creates a brand new network uh
for all of your services don't worry
about that it's kind of outside of the
scope of this um
of this video but it does automatically
create a net us its own separate network
so that it doesn't interfere with any of
the other docker containers
and you do get some extra features and
perks when it comes to having a
custom network like dns so that you can
reference names within your project
but don't worry about that for now so
now if we do a docker ps
you can see that the container is
deleted and everything's cleaned up for
you that's right one command and you can
start and stop
theoretically hundreds of containers
right now
there is one thing i want to tell you
guys
uh when we run the docker
compose up command again what do you
think is going to happen
right because if you take a look at the
steps uh that took place when we ran it
the first time you can see it builds the
image
right it builds the image and then it
starts the container
now if we run this again i want you to
tell me what you think is going to
happen
right your natural guess is going to be
that it's going to build the image again
and then it's going to run the container
well let's figure that out let's see
what actually happens if i run it again
look at this the result was much quicker
and that's because
it skipped the entire build process it
didn't build a brand new image
all it did was it created the network i
did tell you created a network and then
it started our container
and the reason for that is that what
docker compose does
is it looks for an image docker so if i
do docker image ls it looks for the
image based off of that the syntax that
i told you which is
project directory and then the name of
the service and if it sees that that
image already exists
it's not going to rebuild it however
even if we make a change right let's say
we
change the default port to be
four thousand oops right this
theoretically
is now a different um is now a
different um it's a different image
right we've changed something
fundamentally
in the docker file so it should rebuild
the image
if we run it again so let me tear it
down again
let's do a docker compose down
all right and i think i saved it i can
never remember if i do that
and let's do a docker compose up so
let's see if it rebuilt the image
and despite the fact that we made
changes it did not rebuild the image
so now we're essentially running a stale
image right why is it doing that
like i said there's just a simple dumb
check that docker compose does all it
does is just look for an image
named this so if we do a docker image ls
we can see there's an image there it has
no idea that this is a stale image and
that there's been an update it doesn't
know it's
docker compose is pretty dumb it has no
idea
so you have to basically tell it like
listen i've made a change i want you to
rebuild the image so how do we do that
well first of all let me let me tear
things down again and let's go back to
the docker compose up command
and let's do a dash help
and there should be an option that
causes it to force a build
and let me see if i can find it
here we go dash dash build so this when
you run the dash dash build flag it's
going to
tell docker compose to rebuild the image
it has docker compose is not smart it
does not know when it needs to rebuild
the image you need to tell it to
all right so let's rerun this again
we'll do docker compose up
dash d dash dash build this will force a
brand new build
and there you go so now we built a new
image i now
created everything and everything should
be working now
all right so we can tear that back down
uh we can we can tear that back down
change the default port to 3000
save that um just so that we don't break
anything else
and then if you want to you can rebuild
it again with the dash
build flag and so this will bring
everything back up and rebuild it with
the new default port and everything
should be working so let's just double
check
and yeah everything's working perfect
um but that's the idea behind docker
compose there's nothing too
fancy about it obviously
and obviously you're gonna have to take
a look at the documentation
to see other things because eventually
when you get a little bit more uh
familiar with docker and there's other
settings or options or flags that you
want to pass in
you're going to have to update the
docker compose file to
take in those parameters so i just
covered the basic parameters
but there's obviously plenty more within
the docker universe
now we're almost done however there's
kind of one last thing this is kind of a
big thing but you may have noticed
that um we're running
npm run dev right so how do we actually
go into production right because right
now when we run docker compose
everything is with respect to our
development environment because our
docker compose
it creates that bind mount which we
would never want in production
deployment right we don't need it to
sync with anything it's our production
deployment
right and our production deployment
might actually use a different variable
or
a different port uh that express listens
on or could use the same one i don't
actually know
it's going to depend on your company or
how you set up your project
uh but mainly also within our docker
file it's not going to run npm rom dev
instead it's going to run either with my
package.json it's going to run an npm
start
or we can just run nodeindex.js directly
so in the next section i'm going to show
you guys how we can
set up our docker compose file so that
we can have a separate
set of commands for production and a
separate set of commands
for uh development
all right guys so this is going to be
the last section of the video and this
is going to just round out the entire
project i'm going to show you guys how
you can set it up so that
you can deploy your docker containers to
both a development environment
as well as a production environment
because there are going to be some
differences between those two
environments
and the easiest solution is you know you
can obviously have a separate you can
create multiple docker files there's no
rule against it
so you can have one docker file for
development one docker file for
um for production and then you can
basically change out what you want so
really the main change in our case is
just the final command that we run
npm run dev for development and npm
start or
node index.js for production depending
on which one you want to use
if you read online some people recommend
not using the npm command within
container because it's just another
layer between node and the container
so a lot of times they for production
especially you may want to just run node
index.js instead of running npm start
um but i think different people have
different opinions on that
so we can create different docker files
and on top of that we can also create
different docker compose files so you
might you could have one for production
and you can have one for development uh
there's also different
differing opinions on on that some
people like to condense as much into a
single file
and be able to kind of run both of them
off of one file but it really comes down
to personal preference
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
show you guys how to
um do everything as much in one file as
possible so for we're going to use
only one docker file but we are going to
split up the code docker compose files
into two different files
um because um showing you how to do with
two different docker files it's pretty
easy right you just create two different
docker files and then reference them
when you actually run the build command
and then so there's nothing really to
that but i do want to show you how to do
it with one file
um just in case you want to know that
because it was a little bit trickier we
do create like a custom bash script that
actually handles it so let me walk you
through that
so what we're going to do is i'm going
to rename this docker compose file
just for uh just so that we have this
for reference but we're not going to use
this anymore this is just i'm just going
to rename it as backup or something
dockercompose.backup.yaml
and we're going to create a brand new
dockerfile a brand new docker compose
file
and on top of that i'm going to create
two more files
so let's do a new file i'm going to call
this one docker dash
compose dot dev dot yaml so this is
going to have
the configuration specifically for our
development environment and then we're
going to create one more and i'm going
to call this docker dash
compose.prod.yaml
uh so this is going to have all the
configurations specific to our
production environment
and remember we're just going to have
one docker file
all right so we have three docker
compose files
and obviously if you have like a staging
environment you can also create another
one for that
but sorry these are the three this is
the backup just for reference if you
guys want to take a look at that later
but these are the three so the docker
compose file now is going to have any
configurations
that are shared between both
environments uh and what i mean by that
is that
uh like i said in an actual project
you're gonna have
you know six seven ten you might have a
ton of containers so you'll see that a
lot of the configurations
for your containers are gonna be the
same regardless of environment so
there's no point in us
copying and repeating all of those
configurations across both of these
files
we're going to create a shared one for
all the configs that will be shared
between both environments
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
do the same thing we're going to set the
version
like we normally do
and then here services we've got our
node
app
and i forgot to add that tab from spaces
matter and yaml
right and we're going to set the build
to be the current directory like we did
before
and then for my production and for my
development environment i'm just going
to say they're both going to be
listening on port 3000
however keep in mind that maybe in your
environment they're different so
if they're different you don't want to
put in this file because this file is
only for when things are the same
between your production and your
development if they're different you're
going to want to put them
in their respective files this is only
for shared configurations where they're
the same in both environments
so ports we'll set that equal to
3000 colon 3000 like we always have
and then we'll also set an environment
variable to be
um port 3000.
all right so this is the only
configuration that's shared between both
right so our development so in our
development our production environment
basically we're saying that
the the final image is going to be the
same ultimately
uh that we build from our docker file
because both
environments are going to use the same
docker file the ports are going to be
shared so we're going to use port 3000
and this environment variable that we're
setting is going to be shared between
both environments
all right so now within our dev and our
prod file we can actually go in
into our services create a node app
section and then overwrite anything that
we wanted to so we could technically
overwrite the ports
we can add in extra configurations and
so on so let's go to our dev
environment
and i'm actually going to go back to
this and i'm just going to copy up to
node app because it's going to be the
same
so we go into our dev and our node app
and i'm going to set the volumes right
because in our development environment
we want
our bind mounts as well as the extra
anonymous volume
for making sure our node modules folder
doesn't get deleted
so i'll do volume
and we're going to do dot slash actually
if i waste my time retyping that we can
just copy this from here
you just got to make sure the spacing's
okay don't mess up the spacings
uh and i think i messed it up hold on
let's see
so yeah one tab and
one tab there we go
all right and um since this is our
development environment we're gonna pass
in an environment variable
did i spell that right that does not
look right there we go
and we'll say node
underscore env so this is just common
across node applications where
in your development environment you're
just going to set this to development
and then in your production you would
set it up
you would set it equal to production
all right and then the final thing is in
our docker file i'm going to change
this to default to um
it doesn't really matter what we said
here because we're going to overwrite it
so i'll just set this to
either npm start or index.nodeindex.js
whatever you prefer
i'm just going to set this to index.js
by default and remember we can overwrite
any of this in our docker compose file
so in here we can override this that
command
with the command option and we can say
npm
well we do this on the same line npm run
dev right because we have that script
that's going to run node mod so that it
restarts our code in our development
environment
let's save that or save everything and
now let's move on to our compose
prod file but copy the first three lines
as usual
now in our prod file what do we need to
exactly change well let's take a look
we don't in our development environment
we had our volumes we don't actually
need these
the only thing i can think of is we need
to change the environment variable to be
production
and we need to change the command to be
either node index.js or npm start
depending on what you prefer so let's
add those in
so we'll do environment
and then we'll do node underscore env
equals
production and then our command is going
to be set to
node index.js once again you can do npm
start whatever you prefer
so that's pretty much what we need so
let's test this out
i'm assuming i've probably put in a
couple of typos so we're probably going
to have to do a little bit of debugging
all right so what we want to do is the
command's gonna be a little different so
first of all
uh do i have anything running yeah i do
so let's uh let's do a
docker compose down dash v to delete
everything
so docker ps docker images
all right so um now how do we actually
run this
now that we are going to have to run two
docker compose files right because when
we want to run in production we're going
to do the the base docker compose
plus the dev and then when we want to
work in production we do the base plus
the prod
well what we have to do is you do docker
dash compose
and then you pass in the flag for file
and this is important the order actually
does matter so the first
file that we want to pass in is the base
file so we do docker
dash compose compose.yaml
then we pass in the dash flag again to
specify the second file
so if we want to go into development
we're going to pass in the docker dash
compose.dev.yaml
right and so that what's going to happen
is it's going to load all the
configurations from the base file
and then it's going to load all the
configuration from the dev file and then
if it needs to it'll overwrite any of
the configurations that it's been set to
uh from the base and that's why we pass
it in that order
right and then we want to say we want to
bring it up and then remember we want to
run it in detached mode so let's test
this out
hopefully this works uh what did i mess
up
uh dockerdev.yaml what did i mess up uh
must be a mapping not an array
uh let's see oh yeah look i mean you can
see i already messed the indentation the
volume
environment command need to be under the
node app section so that's what broke
let's tab everything up one section
and now let's give that a shot
all right looks like things are working
so hopefully
it looks yep everything looks good so
let's just do a docker ps
and we see our container running let's
go to
our application let's hit refresh looks
like it's working
let's just go to our code make a few
changes
to make sure that things are updating
and that nodemon's doing its job so
let's hit save
let's go back hit refresh look at that
so this is our development environment
and it looks like everything's working
perfectly
and we can go ahead and shut that down
so we'll do uh
remember same thing we do down and we
can pass in the dash v
flag so we can delete those extra
volumes
and it should stop it uh now let's do
the same thing
uh we'll run that same up command but
instead of running dockercompose.dev
let's try the prod version now
all right it should be the same exact
command outside of specifying the yaml
file
so we hit enter perfect let's hit
refresh
all right so there's no exclamation
that's just because we didn't rebuild
the image um but we'll go over that but
let's just try to change things
well i guess there's no exclamation at
the moment so let's hit save
and let's see if it changes and it looks
like it doesn't which is perfect
all right we don't want any changes we
add anything else here
and then hit save remember we're in
production so there is no bind mount and
we shouldn't see any changes
now just to make sure things are working
i'm going to bring this down
i'm going to do a down dash v
and just like before right when we uh
make changes
to anything like our source code or
anything else
since we're in production environment
and there's no bind mount anytime we
make changes to our code we're gonna
have to rebuild our image and we have to
tell docker compose that we want to
rebuild it
so we'll do up so right now it's got all
this nonsense in there so we do up
dash d and then i think it's dash dash
build it's gonna force a new build
right because now we're changing our
code there's no bind mount and so there
so to actually see the update we have to
rebuild the image
right and so now if i hit refresh we see
all of that nonsense
and just as a double check let's delete
the exclamations and let's delete all
that nonsense right
there hit save do we see any changes
absolutely not because remember we are
in production environment so this
confirms
that we now have set up a different
docker compose file for our production
environment and for
our development environment to
accommodate our specific needs for each
environment
now there is one last thing we got to do
because uh there's a little bit of an
issue
and uh i'll show you why uh right now we
what was the last commandment we're
running in production mode right so we
ran the docker compose.prod
and i'm going to do a docker ps let's
just quickly get the name of that docker
image
and i'm going to connect to this docker
container so we'll do docker exec
and copy that a name and then we'll do
bash
all right so here what i'm going to do
is well first of all you'll notice that
we copied a whole bunch of
docker compose files and that's because
in our docker ignore they're not in
there so we can add those in there as
well
and we can just say docker dash compose
star and that'll just ensure we don't
copy anything
uh or any file that starts with the
docker dash compose so this is kind of a
wild card for matching anything after
that
so we'll hit save on that but that
wasn't really the main thing i wanted to
address actually
so if we go into our node modules folder
this is kind of important if i do an ls
this is going to show you all of the
dependencies that we have all the
packages
and there's something very important if
you look at this you can see that node
mod is installed
and you might be wondering why is that
an issue and i want you to remember we
are in production mode right
and our in our package.json we can
clearly see that
nodemon is a dev dependency we don't
need this when we run into production
mode because we're never going to be
using nodemod in production that's only
for development so that it automatically
restarts the note process
when we are developing our project so
how do we actually
prevent nodemon and any other
development dependency from getting
installed because right now it's just
taking up space and doing absolutely
nothing
well in our docker file you can see that
we run an npm install
if you want to actually deploy this to
production right you would normally run
a
you would normally run i think it's a
dash dash only
equals production right and so that'll
prevent any dev dependencies
from getting installed um because you're
running in production mode
so what we have to do now is set up our
docker file to be intelligent enough to
know
uh whether we are in development mode or
production mode and then either run an
npm install or an npm install dash dash
only equals production
depending on um if we are in our
development or if we're in our
production environment
so how exactly do we do that well
we're going to have to basically write
an embedded
bash script so here instead of this line
right here what we're going to do is i'm
just going to go under here
and we're going to replace it with this
i'm going to say run
and we do an if statement
and we're going to say if
and then we're going to do brackets and
this is important make sure you hit one
space
all right this this gave me all sorts of
issues you want to make sure you put
that space
uh and then in quotations we'll do
dollar sign node
underscore env and then
that equals development
and this is also important hit one space
afterwards i don't know why it required
that but
it did and i was troubleshooting that
for a while so make sure you get the
spaces just right
uh so what we're saying is if we are in
a development environment
then we want to run an npm install
however we're going to do an else
if we're not in development so we're in
production we're going to do npm install
dash dash only equals
production
all right and then we end that if
and we no longer need this run command
okay so basically um you know we're
referencing some kind of variable here
called node env
and then when it's set to development
we'll do an npm install or else we'll do
an npm install with
dash dash only equals production now
what exactly is this
well this is an argument that we have to
pass in so here
we do arg node underscore env
so this is an argument that gets passed
into our docker file when it's building
the docker image
and we have to set this value in our
docker compose file
so under dockercompose.dev and dot prod
we're going to have to pass that in so
going to the dot dev file
we are going to actually overwrite
something in our um
in our base docker compose file so
instead of doing just build that
we're going to have to change this up a
little bit so here uh when we do the
build command we're going to override
that
and instead of just doing dot uh instead
of just doing colon dot we can actually
break this down into a few more settings
we can do build colon
and then pass in two properties we've
got the context
and then we've got the args now the
context
remember when we did build dot and
that's just specifying the location of
the docker file
that's what the context is so here we
just specify the location of the docker
file
which is in the same directory so we
just pass in dot once again
and then here under args we pass in all
the different arguments that we want to
pass
uh so here the only thing we care about
right is the one that this docker file
is using and it's called node underscore
env
so we do node underscore env
i'm going to set this to development
because we're in the development
docker compose file and we're going to
copy this
and i'm going to do the same exact thing
in my prod file
and we're going to space that there we
go i think that should be
good yep and we're just going to change
this to production
and let's save everything
and um let's just do
i'm going to bring this down
all right and let's just make sure we
save everything again
all right so now um it should
theoretically
you know run this if statement um
when we want to do an npm install and it
should be able to detect depending on
what the arguments that's passed in so
we're going to run a development fold
first just to make sure everything's
working and then we're going to run it
in production mode after that just to
make sure that that actually made the
changes that we wanted
so let's go back to my up command
i'm going to start off with dev
all right so it's building that
remember i told it i passed in the dash
dash bell flag because we made changes
and
docker compose is not an intelligent and
it will not know that we need
to actually rebuild it so i always pass
in the dash build flag in that scenario
and let's test this out so hit refresh
just says hi there which is fine
uh when we go to our index.js let's add
some exclamation points
hit save refresh
perfect so just the fact that it
restarted automatically and adopted
those changes we know that nodemon was
successfully installed
and so we know that that if statement so
far right here it ran in npm installed
because it detected that we were in
development mode so so far everything's
looking good
uh let's bring everything down
with the with the dash v flag let's
delete that volume
uh and this time we're gonna bring it
back up
but i'm gonna do it in rod
all right and let's just do a docker ps
let's make sure everything's running
perfect
uh let's hit refresh
perfect let me make changes to this code
real quick just to make sure it doesn't
adopt those changes so we'll hit save
let's hit refresh no changes perfect
the last thing that we wanted is let's
log into the container and let's just
make sure it did not install
node mod just to ensure that it did
successfully run the dash dash only
production flag
so we'll do docker exec i t
and then bash
right ls let's go into node modules also
notice how our docker ignore file worked
this time
because it did not import any of the
docker compose files
but let's go into the node modules
folder let's do an ls
uh do you guys see anything with known
mind it should be alphabetical
right so if we go to m
and uh see nothing with node mod so
it successfully is in production mode
and if you do a print nv
uh we can see that
uh i would have thought we would have
set a node dmv set to production too so
everything looks like it's working it's
successfully only installed all of
our um production dependencies
and so guys that's all i wanted to show
you it's just a matter of two commands
uh whoops well looks like we're not
actually gonna get out of the container
but it's just two commands right so you
do docker compose up docker compose down
um and then if you're in production you
pass in the prod if you're in
development you pass in dev that's all
you have to do you've got two different
environments and we can easily spin up
all of our containers
and then also spin them back down with
just two simple commands
up until now we've only been working
with one docker container
and that is our node container which
houses our express application
however what i want to do is i want to
add a second container
because this course is ultimately a
docker course i want to make sure that
you guys are comfortable with
adding in more than one container into
your application
so what we're going to do is we're going
to add a [ __ ] database to our
application
this is going to make our app a little
bit more of a real world type
application
because we'll finally be able to persist
some data so let's head on over to
docker hub
and so here i already searched for
mongodb
but if i just search for again you'll
see that the official image is going to
be the first result so select that
and this is going to have all of the
instructions for working with the
mongodb image
and if we head on over to docker run
example right here we can see that
uh the name of the image is just [ __ ]
so we can do [ __ ] and then the specific
tag or version that we're looking for
so let's go to our docker compose file
and let's add in this new [ __ ] database
and so first of all we have to figure
out where we need to add it inside this
docker compose file
and so if you already forgot under
services this is where we actually
define all of our containers so each
container
is a different service so we have one
service called node app which
is our node container so logically if
you want to add a mongodb container
we're just going to create a new service
so let's go here i'm going to do uh make
sure it's just one tab from the base
oh not one there you go so it's lined up
with the node
app and let's create uh our [ __ ]
container so first of all we have to
name our service we can call it anything
we want
we can call it database we can call it
[ __ ]
we can call it whatever we want i'm just
going to call it [ __ ] because it makes
sense
it doesn't have to be though i just want
to make sure you guys understand that
the service is just for your reference
and you'll see here that we have a the
build
argument and so in our node app right
we're actually building our own custom
image we're taking the uh the base node
image and then we're copying our code
into it
however for the [ __ ] service right
we're just going to use
this built-in image this has everything
we need we don't need to customize it so
anytime you're just using another image
we can use the image property
so we call image and then we call in the
name [ __ ]
so that's going to grab this specific
image and i don't really care about the
version any versions fine so i'm just
going to grab whatever the latest is
and then in the documentation it's going
to show us that we have to pass in some
environment variables
and so you can see here it looks like uh
where is it it's going to be somewhere
down here
here we go so these are the two uh
variables the environment variables that
we have to pass in to make sure our
[ __ ] container
works properly so we have to provide the
root username and the root password
so i'm going to copy these
and feel free to set it to whatever you
want i'm just going to call this sanjeev
and then let's grab the password as well
and i'm just going to say my password
so let's save this and then let's do a
docker compose
up we don't need to do a dash dash build
all right so now we can see that it is
now creating our [ __ ] container
and if i do a docker ps we should now
see two containers we have our
node docker [ __ ] container as well as
our node app as well
so now that we have our [ __ ] container
up and running what i want to do is i
want to connect into the container
and just poke around a bit so let's do a
docker exec
it then the name of the
container
and then we'll do bash so we can take a
look at the file system
and so here since we're connected to the
container we can actually connect
into [ __ ] so if i type in [ __ ] and
then we get a pass in a couple of flags
uh that's gonna be for your user and
password so if i do dash u you pass in
your username and so that's gonna come
from that environment variable that you
set
and we have to pass in p for the
password
and so now we're uh we're logged into
our [ __ ]
uh instance and i want to run just a
couple of [ __ ] commands if we type in
db this is going to show us what
database we're connected to
and so right now we're connected into a
test database i guess [ __ ] creates a
test database so that we have some
database to log into
and we can create a brand new database
uh with the use commands if i type in
use and then the name of my new database
so i'm just going to call this mydb
you can see that it's switched to our
newly created database
and we can run the command show dbs to
list all the databases
and you can see that mydb is not listed
on here and that's just because manga
won't list this database until we have
an
a document or an entry within that
database
and that would probably explain why we
don't see test in that list as well so
let's create an entry
and let's just say we're making like a
an application like a library type
application that's going to store a list
of books
so we can do db then the name of the
collection which is called books
and then we'll just do an insert so here
we have to pass in
uh the properties of that entry so we'll
say
name is going to be
harry potter
all right and so this means we
successfully wrote to our database
and if i type in db.books
this is going to list out all of the uh
documents within
our books collection so here we've got
one entry and we can see the name is set
to harry potter
perfect and if we do a show dbs now we
can see my dv is now listed on there
so let me log out of here and let me log
out of here
and i do want to show you guys one thing
real quick um so if you remember
if your goal is to get into the [ __ ]
shell or the [ __ ] cli instead of having
to do a docker exec it
and then bash and then run where is this
command
[ __ ] dash u instead what we can do is
we can skip the bash and just run
[ __ ] dash u then the username
and then the password
right so just a quicker way to get there
um but now what i want to do is i want
to tear down our container so let's do a
docker compose down
and i'm going to use the dash v like
we've been doing to make sure that we
delete that anonymous volume
and then i want to bring it up and i
know you're thinking like why did we
tear it down just to bring it back up
it's obviously so i can teach you guys
something so let's do up
dash d
and let's give it a few seconds to fully
boot up and then
what i want to do is i'm going to log
back into
the mango shell
and let's do a show dbs right and right
there
something looks odd right our our
database that we created called mydb
is now gone and you might be wondering
well what exactly happened
well think about it we had a container
our [ __ ] container we ran a docker
compose down
which then deletes the container then we
ran a docker compose up
which then creates a brand new container
so this is a brand new container
everything that was in the previous
container has been deleted and this is a
major problem
because this is our database you know we
don't want to lose that information i
mean
if you're doing you know running like
node tests and things like that
then yeah maybe you'd want your database
to kind of start from a fresh state each
time
but you know in a production environment
and even in a development environment
we want to keep all of our database
information so that we don't have to
keep recreating those entries
and especially in a production
environment uh if you lost your database
you know that's
all of your uh that's all of your
application data that's just gone right
at that point you've pretty much broken
your website or whatever application
you're building so you don't ever want
to lose that information
and so how do we actually save that
information and i'm sure you guys
already know this right we use
volumes you know if you look at our
docker compose file
actually let's go to the dev file and
for our node app you remember there's
two different volumes here
so this helps us persist data so let's
do the same thing with our [ __ ]
container so let me exit out here and
let's do a docker compose down
and let's go to docker compose.yaml
and let's add some volumes
and uh you know if we go back to the dev
actually to the dot dev yaml
you'll see that there's two different
volumes that we covered we covered the
bind mount which syncs
the data within the container to a
folder on your local drive
and then we have an anonymous volume so
you know we could theoretically use
either one
if you wanted to be able to poke around
on the on your database data on your
local machine
then you use a bind mount but however i
don't really care about looking at that
data
you know i can just log into the [ __ ]
client and actually just run commands to
see what i need
i don't care about the file system so it
looks like anonymous volume is a better
choice however here's the problem
uh if you have an anonymous volume and i
think i have a few left so if i do
docker
volume ls right you know these are what
anonymous volumes are right
just a bunch of random numbers uh just a
random string or id
i have no idea what these are for uh and
so when you have an anonymous volume
there's a good chance that you may
accidentally delete it
and so i don't feel comfortable using an
anonymous volume for the scenario
because this is our application data
right i want to make sure
i know which volume is storing that data
so what we can do is we can create
a name to volume named volume is exactly
the same as an anonymous volume except
we can give it a
human readable name so let me show you
guys how to do that
and let's go under our [ __ ] service
and let's create a volume
and so here just like an anonymous
volume we have to pass in a path
uh within our container and so to get
that information we have to look at the
docs
and let's take a look so here we go it's
probably under this where to store data
and so you can see they created a volume
and here they used a bind mount so they
stored it on their local directory and
they synced it with slash data
db so this is the folder in the
container that we're interested in
so we want to do slash data slash db and
at this point this is
a anonymous volume you can to convert
this to a named volume all we have to do
is just do a colon
and then just give it a name so i'm
going to call this [ __ ]
db so it's going to save this volume
with the name of mongo-db
right and just to show you the
difference right a bind mount you
provide a path on your local machine to
a path on the container
an anonymous volume you just provide a
path to the container
directory that you're interested in and
then for a named volume you do a name
colon and then the path within the
container but there's one more gotcha
actually let's save this and i'll show
you what happens if we try to run this
as is so let's do a docker compose up
right and it says named volume is used
in a service [ __ ] but no declaration
was found in the volume section
right so it's saying that we have to
declare something and when it comes to
named volumes we do have to declare this
volume in another portion of our compose
in our docker compose file and that's
because a named volume can be used
acro by multiple services so you know if
we had a
um you know like another [ __ ] instance
or another [ __ ] service or any other
service
they can attach to the same exact volume
just like this [ __ ] service does
so all we have to do is at the bottom
we just provide volumes and so here we
just provide a list of all of our named
volumes
so here we just call this mongo-db
that's all you have to do now let's do a
docker compose up
and let's continue uh let's connect into
our [ __ ] client
right remember everything's gone so
let's create
a new database and let's just insert
that same exact entry
all right perfect so now let's exit out
of here
and let's tear down our uh all of our
containers with the docker compose down
and let's bring it back up and let's
just verify
that our information saved so let's do a
docker compose
down now this is where we run into
another issue and that's why i wanted to
show you guys this
so remember we're using this dash v
volume uh this dash v flag
to automatically delete this anonymous
volume um because we don't need it it's
just there for that one little work
around for our node application
however the problem is that this will
delete not only anonymous volumes but
also named volumes
so if we pass in this v flag it's going
to also delete
this database our [ __ ] database a
volume
uh and so we obviously don't want to do
that because we just went through all of
this hassle so that we could save
our database data so we unfortunately
cannot use the dash v flag anymore
so what you're gonna have to do is
remove the dash flee flag
and just do it down and after that
finishes running
if you do a docker volume ls is going to
list out all of your volumes
you can see we have our node docker
mongodb volume so you can see it's given
a nice name so we know exactly what this
is being used for
but we've got all of these um anonymous
volume so you'll see
over time they start to build up uh and
you just have to delete them yourselves
and so there's a nice easy command
called docker
volume i believe prune but don't run it
yet instead what i recommend that you do
is
start up your containers so bring this
back up
and then do a docker volume
and then do a dash dash help
and so we have this prune command which
removes all unused local volumes
so all of the volumes that are being
used right now by the running containers
will not get deleted when we run the
prune only the ones we don't need so
as long as you start up your application
then your mongodb and then whatever
anonymous volume is associated with your
application at the moment
will not get deleted and we can just
clean up all the rest of the data that
we don't care about so if i do a docker
volume prune we should be good to go
and so now if i do a docker volume ls
you'll see we've got significantly fewer
volumes
um these are just the ones being used by
either running or stopped containers
so just make sure you uh i believe you
should start your containers but i could
be wrong
maybe it also saves uh stopped
containers as well so
you might want to double check on that
within the documentation
but i do want to highlight you know just
make sure that only that you only delete
stuff that you don't need all right so
now let's uh let's do a docker ps
we have our [ __ ] container and let's
connect into that container again
and let's just do show dbs and we can
see that our data is still there
and if i do a db.books.find
oh i forgot to switch databases so we
have to use mydb
and then now we do this and there we go
so we've now got persistent data for our
[ __ ] database
so now that our [ __ ] database is up and
running let's set up our express
application
to connect to our [ __ ] database
and when it comes to interacting with
our [ __ ] database
we're going to use a library called
[ __ ] so it's going to make it a little
bit easier to talk to our [ __ ] database
and so here if we pull up the
documentation for mongoose we can see
to install it we just do npm install
mongoose so let's do that right now
all right and so once that's done first
of all we installed a new
package so we have to tear everything
down
remember no more dash v because we have
our database so let's do down
and now let's do an up again
and we want a dash dash build
all right and now going back to the
documentation the first thing we have to
do is we have to import mongoose
so let's copy that line
we'll paste that in there and then we
have to connect to our database so here
we just call the mongoose.connect method
and then we have to pass in our url as
well as some config
options
uh and so the full url if you pull up
the actual [ __ ] documentation
it's going to look something like this
we do mongodb
and then colon slash then your username
your password
the ip address of the host the port and
then some options as well
so under here we'll do mongoose.connect
mongodb slash
and then here you pass in your username
so mine's sanjeev and then
password's gonna be my password at and
then here we have to give the ip address
right and so this is probably where most
of you guys are gonna get stuck
because we have to figure out you know
what is our ip address how does ip
addressing work with docker containers
well here's the thing you know docker
makes it really easy to work with
containers and it automatically assigns
your containers an ip address so if you
ever want to figure out what the ip
address of a container is
first of all do a docker ps uh get all
your docker
containers that are running and then
here you can do a docker network
actually sorry docker inspect this is
going to give us more detailed
information about a container
and we can grab our container name so
here i'm just going to grab our node app
first
just to take a look and so here you're
going to get a ton of information
and if we go all the way to the top
let's take a look at what's up there
a lot of a lot of random information
that we don't really care about
and i believe what we're interested in
is going to be all the way at the bottom
so let's scroll on down to the bottom
and here there's a section called
network settings so this is probably
where we want to look
and so if we keep going down
you can see there's something called
networks and so there's a concept
of uh there's a concept within docker
called networks where you can create
uh more than one network and then put
different containers within those
networks so that
only the containers within a network can
talk to one another and they can't talk
to containers in other networks
so it looks like there's a container
called node docker underscore default
so you know this is this represents our
uh
our directory name so this looks like it
was created by docker compose and it
actually was so docker compose does
create
a brand new network just for your
application so that all of the
containers and services
within your docker compose file will get
placed into that network
and you'll see here we have an ip
address so this is the ip address of our
node application
and then here you can see its default
gateway and so we want to grab the ip
address of our [ __ ] container so let's
do the same thing for our [ __ ]
container
and let's do a docker inspect and then
grab the name of our [ __ ] container
once again it's using that same exact
network that was created
and we can see here this is the
172.25.0.2 so this is the ip address
and i'm just going to copy that we can
paste it in here
and then we want to put the port that we
that's going to run on that mongo's
running on so it's going to be running
on the default port
as long as you didn't change any of the
default configs so 27017
and then we're going to pass this one
property auth source equals admin
all right let's save that and then here
we're going to call uh dot then
so here we're going to pass in an error
function and we're just going to say if
we successfully connect to our database
i just want to do a console.log and
we'll just say
successfully connected to
database and if this failed we'll just
do a dot catch
and we'll say first of all we'll pass in
the error
and we'll just console.log error all
right let's save that and let's see what
happens so
uh if we do a docker
ps and then we're going to do a docker
logs
and we'll connect to that node
application so here
we can see that it said successfully
connected to database
so it looks like we've successfully
connected to the database and
everything's working
however there's something i don't like
right right now
we had to go into docker inspect to get
the ip address
of our container and then put it into
our code however
you know if we stop and start our
containers or if we do a docker compose
down and then back up right first of all
there's no guarantee
that we get the same ip address and even
if we could guarantee the same exact ip
address the first time we run it we'd
have to go in
we'd have to get the ip address and then
update our code and that's just a really
sloppy way of doing things
and so docker actually has a nice
feature
that allows us to make it easy to talk
between containers
right and that's and this feature only
exists when it comes to
custom networks that get created so if i
do a docker network ls
you'll see there's a couple of networks
that we have we've got the bridge and
host network
so these are the two default networks
that come bundled with docker
and then i've got a couple other ones
you may not have these but you'll see
that we have one for
our node docker default so this is the
one docker compose created
this is the custom one that created just
for our application
and when you have a custom network this
only happens with the custom networks
the ones that you create not one of the
two default ones when you have a custom
network
we have dns so when one docker
container wants to talk to another
docker container we can use the name of
that container or the name of that
service
to talk to that container and so if we
go back to our docker dash compose file
you'll see that the service for my node
app is called node app and the service
for my [ __ ] container is called [ __ ]
so i can refer to this container's ip
address
based off of this service name so if i
call [ __ ] within my node app
it's going to automatically grab the ip
address of our [ __ ] container
so if i go back to our index.js
i can change this to [ __ ]
and then here if we do a docker logs
and let me just do a pass in a dash f i
think it's dash f for follow actually
let me just
do a help real quick uh
yeah dash f follow
and here if i save this
you can see we still successfully
connected to the database so
because of dns we're able to resolve
this name
uh this host name to be you know
whatever our [ __ ] container is
and just to show you guys exactly how
that works let's actually log into my
node application container so if i do
docker exec
actually first of all do docker ps and
we'll do docker exec
it
and here we'll drop into bash let's ping
[ __ ] let's see what happens
look at that right it automatically uses
dns to resolve the name of [ __ ]
and it got the ip address of 172 25.0.2
which is our [ __ ] container
so that's how this whole dns process
works so anytime you want one of your
containers to talk to another container
all you have to do is refer to its
service name
and it'll automatically be able to
resolve it because dns is built into
docker
and keep in mind this is only applicable
to networks that you create
it does not work with the default
bridged network okay
and if you want to take a look at your
networks we can actually do a docker
first of all we'll do a dot or network
ls and we can do a docker network
inspect well first of all i have to grab
the specific network i want
so the one that's specifically my docker
compose created
and then we can do inspect
and i messed up the order sorry about
that
it's going to give us some more
information about this specific network
so you can see here the subnet that all
of our containers are going to use are
going to use the 172.25
16. we can see what the default gateway
is
and then we can see under the container
section all of the containers we have so
we've got our [ __ ] container
and we can see the ip address as well as
the mac address of this container
and then we can also see the container
for our node application
and so this has also got an ip address
and a mac address
and i believe and and don't quote me on
this but it looks like
yeah actually that's all i wanted to
show you guys from here so i think
that's going to wrap
up this network section so in the next
section
we're going to make a few changes to our
application so that it's a little bit
easier to work with environment
variables
and we can kind of store them all in
this same area and section
all right so you know one thing i don't
like in our application is that first of
all we're hard coding the url into our
application
you never want to do that instead what i
would rather do
is have this url stored as an
environment variable
and so that way you know when we move to
production you know there's nothing that
we need to change we can just pull the
environment variables
that we set either in docker compose or
on the host machine
so what i want to do is uh within our
base directory i'm going to create a new
folder
and i'm going to call this config and
within here
i'm going to create a new file called
config.js so this is going to store
basically a variable that holds all of
our
environment variables and so here i'm
just going to do a module
dot exports equals
and then here i'm going to store all of
our environment variables
so if we go back to our url there's a
couple of things we need to pull out
here we need the username for our
mongodatabase the password
we also need the ip address uh we know
with docker we can always use
[ __ ] so you know whether you're in
development or environment for the ip
address you can always use [ __ ] so
technically we
don't even need to save that as an
environment variable but you know
down the road you know you definitely
want to think about the future
there may be a time where you decided
you know what i don't want to keep my
database as a docker container
maybe you want to use some kind of
managed service so in that case
we can no longer use dns because it's no
longer running as a container so
if you ever do decide to maybe move your
[ __ ] database
to outside of the docker world and then
have it hosted by
aws or some some other hosting platform
or cloud platform
uh then you would need to pass in a the
ip address as an environment variable so
i like to just store everything as
environment variables just so that we
can plan for the future
so we need those three in the port
because who knows right the port could
change in the future so
let's go back to our config.js and i'm
going to define a property called
[ __ ] underscore ip
and then here this is going to grab
process dot env
dot [ __ ] underscore ip so we're going
to make sure that our docker containers
pass this environment variable in
however if it's not set then we're going
to default to
[ __ ] right so that's what the the
double pipes mean so
if this is set then we're going to use
this value and [ __ ] ip is going to be
stored
to the value of this environment
variable however if this is not set then
this variable is going to be set to
[ __ ] right and so the reason i'm doing
that is because
you know we can always default to [ __ ]
as our ip uh if
if we don't pass anything in
the next thing that i want to do is
we'll grab the the manga port so i'll
call this [ __ ] underscore port
and we'll say process dot env dot
[ __ ] underscore port
and then here we're gonna pass in uh the
default value of two seven
zero one seven
uh then we want the manga user
and we'll pass in the value uh of the
environment variable of
[ __ ] underscore user
and we don't need to default that and
then we need [ __ ] password
all right so now just make sure that
we're exporting it and what i'm going to
do is in our index
dot js file we can then
import those environment variables
so here this is what i'm going to do is
i'm going to change this to a
uh to the template string and then we
can
then grab those values so here this is
going to be the username so we'll just
say
dahlin and then we're going to grab in
[ __ ] underscore
user right and then make sure we let vs
code import it or manually do it
yourself
in the password we want to do the same
thing
then here we also want to pass in the ip
address
and then grab the port as well
right and make sure to let vs code
import all of these for you
and that should be about it technically
we could do the same thing right here
for port
i just like to kind of have a config
file right here that holds all of my
environment variables
so i can know exactly where to look if i
ever need to change anything
and it's just kind of nice to have all
of these in a central location but you
know this
section this part of the the video uh
completely optional
all right let's save all and then let's
so now that we saved it let's go do a
docker logs
and it looks like we got an error so
what happened here
it looks like we got an authentication
failed so we clearly messed something up
let's just make sure we save this and
right it's failing
because well first of all we haven't
passed in any of these uh environment
variables so
uh we don't have a user or a password
right now so we have to pass that into
docker compose
okay and so here right now we've been
using the base
docker compose file for everything uh
and
that's just because i just wanted to
start off with something simple but
uh i think it's time we started kind of
splitting things up between our dev and
prod for [ __ ] so
right now we're just working on our dev
environment so let's uh
copy all of the [ __ ] related stuff
that's for our dev
environment and move it into the
dev.yaml so that we're not cluttering up
the shared configs
so for the environment variables let's
copy those
actually i can copy all of this for now
and go into our dev and then here
we can remove image because that's not
going to change whether it's production
or
development we'll set these environment
variables
and then we also need to set the new
ones as well
so what is this [ __ ] underscore
[ __ ] underscore user
this is going to equal same thing as
this in this case
and actually i'm making a mistake so
this
is going to go under our node app right
this is an environment variable for our
node application
we'll set that to sanjeev and then here
we'll set this
[ __ ] password
equal to my password
and that's all we should need um because
the rest uh can default
to what we're already using so we don't
need to pass those in and then now
i think we should still be tailing this
and we actually have to rebuild the
containers because we pass the new
environment variables so let's stop this
and we're gonna have to do a docker
compose down
and let's bring it back up
and i realized it connected to the wrong
container
we want our node application
all right perfect so now we can see
we've successfully connected to the
database uh and once again guys this
part of the video was purely optional
but i just kind of like having
everything
in a centralized location and i just
want to make sure that we kind of think
about
what our application is going to look
like in the future and make sure that we
can handle making any changes
to where our [ __ ] database is actually
stored all right if we take a look at
the logs right here you'll notice that
we've got a couple of
warning messages so to clean up these
[ __ ] warning messages as well as maybe
kind of clean up our index.js file
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
actually store our url into a variable
and so here i'm going to do const and
then we'll call this [ __ ]
url and i'm just going to store this
url up here
and then in the connect method i can
just call [ __ ] url
then to get rid of those warning
messages i'm going to pass in a few
properties
don't worry too much about these i'm
just it's not really going to affect the
functionality of our application
it's just going to make sure that we
don't see those annoying warnings
all right and so that's all the changes
i wanted to make in this case i just
wanted to clean it up just a little bit
so let's save that let's make sure that
we successfully connected and we should
be good to go
now when it comes to starting up our
docker containers especially using
docker compose
we can run into some potential issues
and that is when we spin up
both our node container as well as our
[ __ ] container we don't actually
know the exact order that these will get
spun up on right docker is just going to
bring them up at the same time or
relatively close to the same time
and that can lead to issues because if
our node container spins up first
it's going to run this code right here
to try and connect to our database
however if our database is not up it's
going to throw an error and then crash
our application
so we need a way to kind of tell docker
to
load up our [ __ ] instance our [ __ ]
container
first so that we can ensure that when
it's up and running only then does our
node container connect to it
and docker compose has a depends on
field that we can use
so if we go into our docker compose.yaml
we'll use the shared one in this case
because we would want the same behavior
whether it's in our production or our
development environment
and under our node app service we'll say
uh depends on depends underscore on
and then we have to pass in the name of
the service that we depend on so we'll
do
slash or dash and then the name of the
service so in this case [ __ ]
and so what this is saying is that
because our node app service
depends on [ __ ] we are going to start
our [ __ ] container first
all right so that kind of helps us so
let's tear everything down
and then let's bring everything back up
all right now we can see that um our
[ __ ] container was started first
and our node app was started second and
uh keep in mind
uh you know if you run this you know
enough times you can confirm that it's
always going to be the [ __ ] container
first because it sees that
our node app is dependent on our [ __ ]
service however this still does not
technically fix
our issue because the only thing docker
does
is it spins up this container first it
has no idea whether
[ __ ] has fully initialized it has no
idea if the [ __ ]
database is actually up and running it
just spins up the container but it
doesn't do any checks to verify that
our [ __ ] database is up and listening
for connections
so despite the fact that we have depends
on it doesn't necessarily
solve our issue it helps a little bit
but once again our application
um you know we could end up catching it
where the [ __ ]
container is up and running but [ __ ]
itself is still down and hasn't
initialized and our node app is ready to
connect to it right and then at that
point our application crashes
and so ultimately there's nothing docker
can really do in this case
or nothing specifically that docker
compose can do maybe if you have an
orchestrator you can kind of work
something out but at the end they
you shouldn't rely on docker or your
orchestrator to handle that instead you
want to
implement some sort of logic in your
application
to handle this scenario where your [ __ ]
database
isn't up and running before your
application starts
and so usually that involves you know if
you try and connect and you're unable to
connect to it you want to keep retrying
until you're able to successfully
connect to it now mongoose in this case
will actually try for 30 seconds
automatically for you after 30 seconds
you'll crash out but for 30 seconds
it will just keep trying and trying and
trying and that's what we want so it's
great that mongoose has this out of the
box
but i just want to make sure that you
guys understand that ultimately
you need to implement some sort of logic
in your applications to ensure that you
can handle this scenario
i'm going to show you a you know as an
example of what something that you could
do and i'm not saying this is best
practice
it most certainly is not it's probably
not the best way to handle this
but i just want to show you how we could
somehow implement some sort of logic
in our application to keep retrying
until [ __ ] is up and running
so let's go back to our index.js and
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
create a function
i'm going to call this connect
with retry
i'm going to take this mongoose method
right here i'm going to drag it right
into my function
and then under the catch section right
here
i'm going to remove this
first of all actually i'll keep the
console.log i don't know why i removed
that
but then if we error out for whatever
reason i mean ideally we should
check to see if it's because we could
not connect to the server but let's just
assume because it's trying to connect
that any error we get is because we can
connect to it
we'll say set timeout
and then we'll call the same exact
function so we'll do connect
with retry and then we'll just say after
five seconds so what's going to happen
is
we're going to call this function when
we start our application
and then it's going to run it's going to
try and connect and if we can't connect
to it
what we'll do is we'll wait five seconds
so that's
the purpose of the set timeout we'll
wait five seconds and then we'll just
call connect with retry so we'll just
call this function again
and then we'll try and connect and then
we'll do the same thing we'll wait five
seconds and just keep trying this so
this is gonna loop forever
until we can finally hit this then
statement right which is when we
successfully connect to it and then we
can break out of this function
uh so that's just an example of how you
would implement something within your
application i'm not saying it's a best
practice i'm sure there's
something there's some negative aspect
as to the way i've implemented
this and maybe it's not best practice
i'm just here to try and
kind of sell home the point that you
need to make sure your application
handles the logic don't rely on an
orchestrator
don't rely on docker or docker compose
because none of them can truly guarantee
you that your [ __ ] database is fully up
and running
uh before your application starts make
sure your application is intelligent
enough to handle that scenario
and so the last thing that we got to do
is we got to call that function so
here we just do connect with retry
let's save that and now
to actually test this out uh first of
all let's do a docker
first of all let's tear everything down
and now i'm going to show you a command
that we have or
an option that we have with our docker
compose up so if we run up again
with the dash v if we just run this like
this it's going to start all of our
container all of our services
however we can tell docker compose to
only start up specific services
so in this case we would want to bring
up
our we would want to bring up
just our node application so if i do a
dash dash help you can see at the top
we can just provide our service names
uh where is it i think it's somewhere
here it's listed somewhere if you check
it but it'll
list out uh you can specify just the
services you want to start
so if i do uh
and first of all that shouldn't be dash
v that should be dash d sorry so here i
can type in
node app right and so that's just coming
from
our service name and so this should
start just our node application so if i
hit that
we see a little bit of an issue right it
started our [ __ ] container so why
exactly did it start our manga container
well that ultimately comes down to the
fact that we use this depends on flag
so because this service depends on [ __ ]
right it's going to start [ __ ] no
matter what
so let's tear this back down and i'll
show you how we can start just our node
application
now here we do up dash d
and then node app
and let's do a dash dash help
and let me do that before the name of
our service so here
and there should be a specific flag and
that is no depth right here so that says
don't start linked services or it's
basically saying you don't need to start
the dependencies so when we start up
our node application despite the fact
that we depend on [ __ ]
it will not start up all of any of our
dependencies so that's the exact flag
that we want
so let's hit an up arrow remove that and
then the dash dash
i already forgot what it was no
no deps
and then we want to call our service
name which is no dash app
all right so now it's going to start
just our node application
let me do a docker ps just to confirm
perfect
and then let's do a docker logs
and then we'll call this
and then dash f so let's take a look at
our application
and let's see what happens
and i can't remember if i did a save all
i mean let's just do a save
there we go okay so we can see that
[ __ ] tried to connect
right and it said connection timed out
all right and so
uh you know by default i think it [ __ ]
waits like 30 seconds again afterwards
or something like that
so let's see uh if manga if my for loop
actually wasn't a four lift but if my
repeating function works so we should
ideally see the same exact error message
when it tries to reconnect in a few
seconds
and there we go so i don't know if you
guys saw that flash before you but
uh it spitted out the error once again
so this confirms
that uh my application is continuously
trying to connect to [ __ ]
so let's bring up our [ __ ] container
now so we can do a docker compose up
and then here we can remove all of these
flags and just bring up our [ __ ]
service
and so now if i run the the docker logs
again for our node application
when it tries to retry once again it
should then successfully connect
and there we go so now we can see that
we've successfully connected
and this confirms that our node
application is intelligent enough
to handle a scenario where our [ __ ]
database is not up and running
at a specific moment in time so it will
just continuously retry over and over
and over and over again
until the database is finally up and
running
so now that our node application can
successfully talk to
our mongodb instance i think it's time
we started to build out a demo crud
application i was trying to think of
what would be the best example project
and i
and i realized that uh you know
searching through youtube i could not
find a
single a tutorial that covered how to
build a to do application so that's
exactly what we're going to build
i'm just kidding i would never build the
most annoying application
instead what i'm going to do is i'm
going to build the second most annoying
application which is a blog application
so let's get started now keep in mind
when we start building out the express
side of things i'm going to move a
little bit quickly
just because i want to make sure this
video focuses more on the docker side of
things i'm going to expect you guys to
have a little bit of background
when it comes to express already so i'll
move quickly
if you have trouble keeping up you know
i would recommend watching another
tutorial on how express works
and then coming back to this but i want
to make sure that anybody watching this
whether they're interested in express or
node that they can follow along because
the
idea behind all of this is all about the
docker side of things and how we can
build a
development to production workflow so
let's start off by creating a couple of
folders
so the first folder we need is one for
our models this is going to store our
mongoose models
i will create a new folder for our
controllers as well
and we'll create a new folder for our
routes
and so let's start off by building our
models and i'm going to create a new
file and we'll call this um
our post model so this is a blog
application so we need something to
represent our blog posts
and from here we want to import mongoose
and we'll do const post schema
and here let's think about the
properties we want to give it so it's
got to have a title
and we'll say this is going to be a type
of string
and then we're going to say this is
required
and we'll set that to be true and if
they don't include a title we'll say
we'll throw an error and say post must
have title
uh the next next property you should
have would be a body
so this is going to be the content of
the post so once again there's going to
be a type of string
and we'll say required as well
and we'll say uh post must
oops must have body alright so this is
going to be our blog model
fairly straightforward uh and then here
let's just make sure we export it
and now let's create our controllers so
that we can handle
creating reading updating and deleting
our posts
we'll call this post controller
and so first thing we want to do is we
want to import our post model so that we
can actually
you know interact with our database and
create posts
and then we'll do export and then we'll
define our
controller for retrieving all posts
we'll do get
all posts
and this is going to have a request
response and
next as well though that's optional for
a route
all right and the way to retrieve all
posts with mongoose is we can just say
const posts equals
post dot find so that's going to connect
to our database and retrieve all of our
posts based off of this model
however there's a couple things we have
to do first of all this is um an
asynchronous
method so we have to do async await
sorry that should be a wait
and then this function needs to be an
asynchronous function and then
anytime you're working with anything
that could potentially error out we need
to
throw it in a try catch block so we'll
do try
and i'm just going to move this into the
try statement
and if it's successful we want to make
sure that we send a response and we'll
say status 200
and here we'll say first of all status
of success
and we'll say results actually we'll do
data
and we'll just pass in posts
and then also uh anytime we return an
array of any kind i usually like to
include a results count so we'll say
uh posts dot length so however many
posts we retrieve
we also return that as well
and then if there's an error let's just
send a status
400 i probably not the correct error
code but remember this
the point of this video is not about the
express side of things i just need to
get something up and running
just to show you guys how all of this
integrates together
and we'll say status fail
and that's all right so we've got the
logic for retrieving all
posts let's get the logic for
[Music]
retrieving an individual post
is also going to be an asynchronous
method they're all going to be
asynchronous
and i'm going to just copy and paste
this and we're going to just change a
few things but for the most part
all of this is going to be fairly
similar and then here the only thing
that we have to change is
post dot find by
id and then we need
rec dot params dot id so uh you know
when you're retrieving a post what we're
gonna do is we're gonna have the user go
to
uh localhost you know colon
3000 or whatever and then say you know
api
v1 i'll skip that for now and we'll say
they want to go under the posts
and then here they would pass in uh
whatever id so if they want the
post with an id of five they would pass
that and to retrieve that value we just
do rec.params.id
and you know within our route we're
actually going to just do call and id so
that we can pass whatever value
the request is into the params.id
so we retrieve that we don't need the
results because it's not going to be an
array
and don't have to do this but we're
going to only return an individual post
so we'll just say post
and that should be all so then the next
thing we want to do is for creating a
post
and actually instead of writing this out
let's just copy this exactly
and we'll call this create post
and then we'll remove this and we'll
just say post.create
and we want to just pass in rec.body so
uh the
title and the body that the that the
front end sends it's going to be
attached to our body property so
that should be all that we need we can
return the same stuff
all of that looks good all of that looks
good
and then we just need two more we need
update and delete
and we're going to copy the get one for
the update
so this will be update post
and the method we're going to use is
find by id
and update and so first of all we have
to get
we have to pass in what the id is so
just like we did for
uh get one post we can just pass in
rec.params.id
and then we have to pass in the body so
rect.body which is going to have the
content of our post
and then a couple of other things that
are optional
so i forget what these do
just pass it in i know run validators is
going to ensure that even when you
update
it's going to um it's going to
make sure that you know like we go back
to the models
even when we update it's going to check
to make sure that we have a title
uh as well as a body as well so it's
just going to do all of the
mongoose schema validation even on an
update which it doesn't do by default
and i believe this is to return the new
post that gets created but i could be
wrong
and then lastly we want to do our delete
so let's just copy this
and we'll change this to delete post
and all we have to do is let's delete
all of this
and we're going to call find by id and
delete
and we just pass in rec.params.id
and in this case there's no data so we
can just pass in
null or just not even include that
actually
all right so we've got all of our crud
methods done our controllers are set
uh the next thing that we have to do is
just define our routes so let's go into
our routes
and let's create a file called uh post
routes
dot js
and in here we want to import express
and let's import our post controller as
well
now let's create a new router
right and then let's start defining our
routes so we do router
dot route and then the specific url so
this is just going to be
the slash url the slash path
and then now we can chain in what we
want for our get method
and then what we want for our um
[Music]
our post method as well so get and post
remember they're always going to be
if we actually take a look at the url
it's going to be you know localhost
3000 and then if you go to slash
get then it's going to call this
specific route and if you go to slash
post
it's going to create a new a new post
so that's how that's going to work so
let's uh add the controllers into here
so
the get method is going to call the um
the post controller uh get all posts
so post controller dot get all posts
and then for the post method this is
going to create a post so we'll do post
controller
dot create post
then let's go to our router instance
again and do route and then here
the route is going to be actually slash
colon id
and so anytime you pass the id you're
usually going to do a
either an update or a delete
or get one post or an individual post so
here we'll do
get and then we'll pass in our post
controller
dot uh get one post all right and then
we'll also do a
dot update no sorry not update patch
and we'll call post controller dot
and then we also want a delete which is
going to be postcontroller.delete
and then we'll do module.exports equals
router
and now let's go back to our index.js
file and let's
wire that router up
so here we'll call it post router
which equals require and then our path
two routes and then post routes
and then uh right under here we'll say
app.use
and then we want to pass in the url so
here we can say
slash posts and then
post router so what is this what's
actually what's actually happening here
so
uh basically if someone sends a request
uh
and it has uh and it looks like
uh you know localhost call colin 3000
slash posts so if that first keyword
after 3000
uh is posts it's going to send it to our
post router
and then that's going to go to here so
this is where our post router is defined
and so it's going to strip off that
posts now and then we're just gonna
be left with either uh colon three
thousand slash or colon three thousand
slash id
so then it's gonna match one of these so
that's all i'm trying to do however
i usually like to do uh slash api slash
v1 so here you pass an api so that
you know that this request is for your
api in case you're hosting your front
end
and your back end within the same domain
and then i like to specify the version
of our api so this way at least it keeps
your different versions independent
so you can start a second version and
they can run side by side
and so now basically if there's a
request to api v1 slash posts
it's going to go to our post router
and let's save everything
so looks like nothing's broken but let's
test this out
i'm going to bring up postman and let's
just say api
v1 posts
and let's do a send and look at that so
it looks like things are working so we
can see it's a success we got no results
because we haven't created anything
uh so that works let's now try to create
an entry so we'll do post
and then go into our body and then let's
do uh raw
and then json and then here let's change
this
so we need a title i'll call this my
first post
and then we need a body
and we'll say i don't know body of first
post whatever
let's send it looks like we
got an error so let's see what happened
now we went to post routes and under
actually let's go to our controller
where we create a post
and then here let's just do a
console.log
e so that we can see exactly what's
happening
and it says oh post must have a body it
does have a body
and i realize i know exactly what
happened so um
to actually attach the body of a request
onto our
request actually i worded that weird um
but
for express to actually take the body of
the actual request and attach it to that
request object
that our controllers have access to we
actually have to pass in a middleware
so let's define that middleware real
quick
under our index.js
right here we'll just say
app.usexpress.json so that's going to
ensure that the body gets attached to
the request object
and now if i hit send we can see that it
successfully created the post we got the
id back from mongoose so that worked
if i go back to the get and then get all
of our posts we should see that show up
perfect
let's update now let's update that post
so i'm going to do slash and then we got
to copy the id of this post
and i'm going to change this to my first
post updated
let's hit send and we can see that the
title got changed to updated
and if i do a get and remove that id
my first post updated so we've
successfully updated a post
uh let's try to get an individual post
so let's send that we got the individual
post
and then let's delete that post as well
let's delete it
success we do a get now nothing perfect
uh let's just add a few entries just so
that we can have something in our
database so i'm going to go to post
let's just create a couple so got one
and change this to
second post
third post and then let's go back to our
get
method right here and let's send and we
should get three entries perfect
so now we've got a basic crud
application
and i think that's a good stopping point
for this section
okay so we got our basic crud
functionality going with our blog posts
however
i want to start to implement a user sign
up
and login functionality and the reason i
want to do this is because
i want to introduce one more container i
want to introduce a redis container
so we're going to use redis for
authentication but to do that
we have to implement the whole user sign
up and login
uh flow so that we can actually get that
wired up to our
our docker application so let's quickly
get started on that i'm going to
try to blitz through it as quickly as
possible once again so that i can show
you how we can wire up a
redis container
and so you know just like we did with
our posts
we're going to create a user model
we'll import mongoose
and then let's define our schema so
we'll do const user schema
and there's going to be just two
properties the username and password so
we'll set user name
is going to be a type of string
and this is going to be required so
we'll set require to be true
and then if they don't provide it we'll
give it an error of user must
have a username
then we have to pass in another property
which is unique
so we can't have two users with the same
exact username so this is going to do a
little bit of validation ensure that
uh if we're creating a new user that
that username is not already taken
i'm going to copy this and for the
second property it's going to be the
password so i'm just going to change
this to be
password
type string we don't need it to be
unique required and we'll just say user
must have a password
so here we'll say const user
equals mongoose.model
user and then user schema
and we'll just say module.exports equals
user
we've got a model let's actually set up
the controllers now
so we'll call this auth controller
and let's import our user model
and let's set up our controller for
signing up
and then within our try catch block
let's uh let's do user dot create
and we can just call in rec.body which
should have the username and body
and then we'll await this
and we'll set that you to new user
and then here we'll just do res status
201 json
and we'll say status as success
and will return the new user
and if this fails we'll just do a res
dot status 400
and we'll say status fail
so let's try this out well actually
first of all we have to wire this route
up
so let's go to our routes let's create a
new route we'll call this
user routes
and we'll say const express
equals require express so that we can
get that router object
we'll do router equals express
dot router
and we'll say router.post
and this will be for signup
we get our auth controller so we have to
import our auth controller
and we'll call up the sign up method
and then we'll export that
and then we need to wire it up into our
index.js
so here we'll do const user router
and just like we did before we're going
to do app.use
here let's specify the url that should
get routed to so we'll go to
slash api v1 slash
uh we'll just say users and then we'll
pass in that user
router
and let's save all files
and let me just make sure that there
aren't any errors so it looks like
everything's good
and let's try this out now
i'm going to create a new request it's
going to be a post this is one that's
going to go to users
slash sign up
and then we need to pass in our body
it's going to be json
say user name is set to
sanjeev
password is set to
password let's try this out
and it looks like it worked it's perfect
a couple of issues though obviously
first of all uh you know i don't want to
return back the entire user
but really the bigger issue is is that
first of all we're just storing this in
plain text
or password into plain text so let's fix
that and so to do that we need to
install a new library and that's going
to be the bcraft library so that we can
hash our password so i'm going to stop
this
for now i'm going to do an npm install
bcrypt js
and we got to do a docker compose down
and then back up
and we've got to do a rebuild as well of
the image
we'll do up dash d dash dash build
all right so everything's back up and
running so let's uh hash our password so
if we go back up to the auth controller
under sign up
uh what i'm going to do is first of all
i'm going to
grab the username and property from the
body
with a little bit of destructuring
and let's import bcrypt
and then here we'll do const hash
password
equals and then we'll just do an await
and then do bcrypt.hash
and then here we're going to hash the
password
and then we have to pass in a value so
this is going to be the strength of the
hash we're just going to pass in a
a value of 12 i think that's a standard
number that people use
and then when we do new user we have to
change this now
so we'll pass an object and the username
will be set to username and then the
password
it's going to be set to a hash password
let's try that out now
so now if we sign up i'm just going to
put a 1 here
we can see now that it has a hash
password so perfect
now let's implement the login
functionality so we're going to define a
controller for login
and once again we're going to
destructure out the username and
password
and i realized first of all back in our
sign up let's make sure we get this in
our try catch block
because this could fail as well
and here we're going to find our try
catch block as well actually
i'm going to copy and paste it let's
save us some time
so first things first is let's delete
this
and what we want to do is we want to
find uh you know we want to check our
database to see if we have a user with
that username
so let's do const user equals await
user.find1
with a property of username
and then we'll do an if statement to see
if user was found
actually we'll say if user was not found
then we'll just send a res.status
400 well technically it would be a 404
it doesn't really matter
json and then we'll just say
status whoops
fail and we'll just say message
user not found
uh however if we did find a user
actually we want to do a return
uh but if we did find a user then we
want to say we want to first of all
check to see if the password's correct
so when you hash a password what we have
to do is we have the hash password
stored in the database
and then we have a the password that the
user is trying to
uh log in with so what we have to do is
we have to hash the password the user
tried to log in with
and compare that hash with the hash
that's stored in our database and if
they equal the same
then that means the user should be able
to log in so we'll say
bcrypt dot compare
and we pass in the password that the
user tried to log in with
and then we pass in uh from our user
object which it represents the entry in
our database we'll say user
and then grab the hash password within
the database
and we'll take this we'll do an await
and then we want to store the result
with into a variable called maybe is
correct
so that means his password is uh good
and then we'll say if
is correct
we'll do a wreck res dot status
200 dot json
and we'll say status success
however if it's not correct
then we'll just send a response status
400 again
json and we'll say status
fail with the message
incorrect username or password
and we'll remove this we don't need this
anymore
all right and let's save that
and now let's go back to here so we did
a sign up let's do a login
and actually we have to define our
routes so you can see here we just have
a route for
sign up let's copy this and let's create
one for login as well
it's going to be pretty much the same
thing
login it's also going to be a post
method
and then in this case there's going to
be a login
so we created a user with this username
and this password so we should be able
to just change the url to login
and this should work so let's try this
out and we get a status of success
if i put in a different password
incorrect username or password
change it to the correct password and
then uh change the username to
something that doesn't exist and we can
see user not found perfect
all right so we've got our user we've
got the
user sign up and login working
relatively speaking but the next thing
that we want to do is we want to
actually
handle the authentication side of things
so when the user logs in how do we
actually store that state within our
application
and we're going to use sessions to do
that so we'll tackle that in the next
video
all right so now let's actually go ahead
and implement authentication in our
application because right now a user can
sign
up and it can log in but how do we
actually make it so that to
you know retrieve posts maybe modify
posts a user has to
log in and authenticate first well we're
going to use
something called express session so
there's really two different ways of
handling authentication
we can use sessions or we can use json
web tokens
i decided to use sessions because uh
really i went through all of this
process just to show you that
that we can add in a redus database so
we can use a readers database
to store our sessions and you'll see
that uh wiring up an express session
to work with readers is dead simple uh
if you actually scroll to the bottom
it actually shows you uh all the other
compatible session stores so if you want
to store it
within the [ __ ] database that we're
already using you can do that if you
want to store it within a postgres
database
if you want to store it in memory you
can but what we're going to do is we're
going to do it with
rita so that i can show you how to
deploy one more container
so let's just search for redus and here
you can see connect readers
and this will walk you through the whole
process of getting
express sessions wired up with a readers
database now what we're going to do is
before we do that let's go ahead and
actually get ourselves
a reader's database so let's go to our
images
in our docker hub and i'm gonna search
for reedus
and there's the official image is gonna
be the first result so let's add this so
the name of the image
is going to be redus so let's go to our
docker compose
dot yaml and let's wire this up
so under [ __ ]
under that service let's create a new
one and give it any name you want but
i think redus makes sense and then here
we want to pass in the image and that's
going to be read us and once again i did
this in the shared file because both in
our production
and our development environment we're
going to need a readers database
now at this point you know right now if
you take a look at my setup
and i do docker ps you can see
everything's running so uh you know
normally you think that you would have
to do
a down and then
and then an up right afterwards but
there's a shortcut
uh what we can do is since we made a
change to docker compose.yaml
we can do an up again even though
everything's already up and running and
docker compose is smart enough to know
to detect any of the changes that we've
made and spin up the necessary
uh spin up the necessary services that
we've defined so if we do up
and then once again do dash d what's
going to happen is it's going to see
that we added that readers database
and it's going to spin us a spin a spin
up a reader's database
all right and so you can see both of
these are already up to date so it was
able to tell that nothing's changed
there
but we did add the reader so it's going
to go ahead and pull that up so you'll
see moving forward i'm just going to do
i'm just going to run the up command uh
just to get make any changes
take effect uh instead of having to do
it down and then and
up because that's just too long of a
process
all right so we've got our redish
database uh now let's go back to here
and let's see how we can
wire up this connect we just express
session so we have to do
an npm install and then we have to
install these three libraries so we have
to install how
redis because we are interacting with
the reader's data space we do have to
install express sessions because
we're using the sessions functionality
and then to wire those two up together
we need the connect readers library
all right so let's do a npm install
i already forgot what libraries i need
to copy this
i'll install those
and then now uh you know like i said we
can do it down
uh docker compose down and then do a
docker compose up with the dash dash
build because we did install
new dependencies so we have to rebuild
our node image
however what we can do is just do an up
dash d dash dash build
but and that's going to you know rerun
everything
for us so we don't have to bring it all
down however there's one more
issue so if i do a dash dash help
uh you're going to see that there's this
renew anonymous volumes
so when you have a a database
sorry not a database when you have your
containers already up and running
and then you do another up and you want
to rebuild the image what's going to
happen is
that the already running container for
our node application is going to
grab the old anonymous volume and the
old anonymous volume has all of our
old dependencies and packages that we've
installed but we've installed some new
dependencies like
uh redus and so we need to force docker
to renew a new anonymous volume so
instead of using the old one we needed
to create a new one
and not use the old node modules folder
that doesn't have redus
or express sessions so you can just do a
down and then an up with the dash dash
build
like you normally can or you can do just
an up again
with the dash dash build and then make
sure you pass in the dash
capital v to ensure that we create a
brand new anonymous volume
all right so we've got all of that let's
take a look at the example you'll see
it's pretty easy
um we have to uh import radius
uh sorry not radius redus express
sessions we have to create a redis store
and so you just it's literally just copy
and paste up to here
uh and then here under readers under our
create client method we have to specify
how to access our readers database
and then we just pass in this specific
middleware that we create
so let's get to it so let's go back here
and let's go to our index.js
and we're going to import sessions first
so we'll do a const session
equals fire
express that session
then we need to import redus
and then we have to define our vita
store so we'll do uh let in this case
so do let beat us store
equals require
and then we need connect dash redus
and then we pass in session
and then let's define our reader's
client so we'll do let
fetus client equals require
sorry not require we want read us dot
create client and then here we have to
pass in two things we have to pass in
uh the uh the url the host url as well
as the port that the
redis server is going to be listening on
all right so let's um
let's go to our config.js and let's
define that here as an environment
variable so we'll say
uh redus underscore url when i say url
this is just going to be the i p
address so i'll just say process dot env
dot redus underscore url
and then if that's not set to anything
we're going to default to
redis right remember we have the dns uh
at our disposal so uh you know anytime
any one of our containers wants to talk
to our readers database
and it needs to know the ip address we
can just reference redus
so if i go back to config.js i'm just
going to default to read us i'm
you know in production and in
development i'm never actually going to
pass this url in
it's just there so that in the future if
i do decide to have a reader's database
that's not a docker container and that i
can't actually resolve
using redus then i can just pass it as
an environment variable and then i can
connect to like maybe a managed
avetis server
so back here we'll pass in host
as bdis underscore url
and then we also have to pass in the
port so what is we're going to use the
default port for everything but let's
define a
environment variable for that so we'll
call this redus
underscore port and this is going to be
set to process.env.redis
underscore port
and we're going to define we're going to
default to whatever the default port is
for redus which is 6379
all right and then right down here
before our first middleware here
i'm going to define a brand new
middleware for our
sessions so here we'll then pass in
session
and then we have to pass in an object so
the first thing that we do is we have to
pass in our store
so here we'll call it new reader store
and then we have to pass in our client
that we created so it's going to be
client
and then we're going to reference our
readers client right here
all right then the next thing that we
have to pass in is a secret so this is
just
a random secret that we store on our
express server
uh that we use uh when we are handling
the sessions
so this can be any string so what i'm
gonna do is i'm gonna create an
environment variable for that as well
so we'll go to back to our config
and i'm going to create one and i'm
going to call this a session
underscore secret and we're going to
grab this from process dot env
session secret
and so this is going to be session
secret make sure you
import that and then we have to pass in
some properties for our cookie
that we send back to the user
and so if you want to take a look at the
properties that we're going to pass in
go to the original express
session page and then here under the
options
for cookie you'll see the different
options that we have so we've got uh
expires so actually we don't even want
that we want max age
so i think it's somewhere here
anyways i'm just going to pass in a
couple of the ones that i'm going to use
and then you know if you guys want to
read up on that feel free to
but it's not really that important from
a docker perspective
so we're going to do secure i'm going to
just set that to false
just to simplify our application resave
set to false save initialized
http only is going to be set to true
and then max age this is going to be set
to
uh so this is set in milliseconds so i
just want this cookie to last 30 seconds
it's gonna be a little bit
i want it to be that short just because
it's easier to demonstrate how
these cookies work i'm gonna do 30 000
seconds sorry 30 000 milliseconds which
equates to 30 seconds
and i know http only this is just used
for scenarios where
uh your your javascript on the browser
will not be able to access it so http
only means that javascript can't access
it
all right so we've defined a couple of
new environment variables so let's go
back to
our um docker.com docker compose file
and uh well first of all let's go to dev
anyways
uh so this is going to be the
the environment variables for our
development environment so let's go down
to redus
and let's set our environment variables
and once again i made a mistake these
aren't set for the redis server this is
going to be set for our node app
and the only thing we need to pass in is
our session secret so we'll do session
underscore secret and then just pass in
some string so i'm just going to call
this
secret why not it's just an arbitrary
arbitrary string just think of it as
like a password for your for your
sessions
and so now let's do a docker compose up
however if we just do a docker compose
up
you'll see that nothing happens because
well actually something did happen this
is actually perfect so
it recreated the container just because
we changed a few things
uh we changed our environment variable
cell it was able to start that and let's
do a docker
ps we'll do a docker logs and then
where's our node app right here
and then we'll just do dash f
and it looks like
i forgot to import reader's url so if i
go under index.js
you know this was never imported well it
actually is imported i just imported it
down here so
we just have to cut that out and then
move it below this line
and then on port 18
i never actually imported so this is
going to be set to
port and let's import
actually is that defined here we need to
make sure yep we didn't we never oh it's
regis underscore
port okay
import that so make sure you import it
there and i think this should fix our
issues
uh looks like things are good so far so
let's
uh well actually technically nothing's
done yet but
all right so we've got our sessions
wired up the next thing that we have to
do is we have to
create a session whenever a user logs in
all right so now that we've got our
sessions wired up let's try to
log in again and see if anything's
changed so i'm going to do a post
request to our login route
and i'm going to pass in the credentials
to a user that's already been created
and then we'll hit send we get a status
success
and you'll notice that under this
cookies tab there's a one so this
implies that we received a cookie
with the value of one and so this is
what our cookie looks like
uh you'll see the domain is set to
localhost because that's what our server
is running on
and then you'll see our expires section
which is going to expire in 30 seconds
and then some of the other properties
like http only set to true
and then secure secures um basically if
you have set secure to true
that means it will only work with https
um
i'm not going to go over how to set up
ssl and https and all of that
for this video but uh you know in a
production environment you definitely
want this set to true and then usually
in development you just leave it set to
false
so let's log in what i want to do is i
want to actually log in
to our redis database and just show you
what that looks like what that session
looks like
within the database so i'm going to uh
we'll
control c out of this
and then let's just do a docker
exec well first of all let's do a docker
ps let's get the name of that container
so
read us and we'll do a docker exec
it and we'll drop into bash
and from here we can just type in redus
or radius cli and so that's going to
drop us into the
into our regis database however once
again just like we did with manga we can
kind of shorten that and just do
redus cli and so
now we're in redus and to see all of the
entries within our
our readers database all we have to do
is just type in keys and then star
and you'll see that it returned an empty
array and you might be wondering why
they return an empty array we have a
session
well if you recall where i set
some properties on my cookies and my
sessions is that the
that this is only going to last 30
seconds so the session dies after 30
seconds so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to re-login this should create
a new session
and then now let's quickly run the same
command and you can see we have a
session right there and if you want to
see the details for a session
you can type in get and then the key for
that so here we just copy that
and i forgot the other
quotes and there you go so this is the
details of that session
it's got some information about the
cookie and a few other things
but with this session we can add any
information that we want into this
session so
what we ideally want to do is when the
user logs in we want to store the user
information
within this session and so if that user
information is
in that session then we know he's logged
in if it's not that means he's not
logged in
and the nice part about doing this is
that we can store any information we
want in the session
even you know information that's
uh should be private to the user because
the user never gets to see the session
this session resides in our readers
database
it never gets sent out to the web
browser the user is trying to
connect from so to do this let's go to
our auth controller
and it's very simple so let's go under
our login section
and right before we actually implement
the logic for logging in
so right under is correct what we can do
is
we can say rec dot session so this is
how you
um access this session object it's going
to be attached to the
request object and we can add in a new
property called user
we can create any property we want and
we'll just set that to
uh let's see where is the user we'll set
it to user
and so that's going to take the user
object that we found from our database
and only if our password our login is
correct
will we then log or we will assign this
user object
to our session so let's save this
should restart our app and let's log in
again
and now i'm going to do keys star
we have our session object and then i'm
going to do
a get
and now take a look at this so here
starting at this section right here this
is our user object we've got the mongodb
id that assigned it we've got the
username and the password so this is how
we tell
that a user is logged in
and then after 30 seconds you'll see
that it goes away
and so if we do a keys star it's gone
now so now that you have an idea of how
the sessions work let's go back into our
index.js
and just change this value because
obviously 30 seconds is way too short
uh we can change so i mean just add
whatever you want i just added a couple
of zeros
however long you want a user to be
logged in this is the value you set in
there remember we use milliseconds of
course
and uh before we move on a couple other
things so after a user
signs up we also want to do the same
thing so after he signs up we want to
make sure that we log him in
by doing rec.sessions.user
and set that equal to new user
and let's test that up so i'm going to
go to sign in or sign up
and we'll just do sanjeev five
all right that worked we got a cookie
let's do that and
let's get the details for that session
and we can see it did not work
because i do not see any information
about my user so let's take a look and
see what
we might have broke and i already see
what i broke so it shouldn't be sessions
it should be session
and so let's sign up with a six this
time
we have a new user
and so there we go so now we can see
username sanjeev6
so now whether we log in or sign up it's
going to assign the user
uh to our session and so now we can
access that user whenever we want to
access posts
so now that we have our sessions
tracking where their users logged in
let's set up the logic to make sure that
for a user to either create or delete or
update a post
or even get post depending on how your
application works they have to be logged
in
and the way we can accomplish that is by
using express middleware
and a middleware is nothing more than a
function that runs before your
controller
this function is going to have a little
bit of logic and all it's going to do is
it's going to check
that sessions object to see if there's a
user property attached to it
and if there is a user property to it
attached to it then
it will then forward the request onto
the controller so the controller can
handle that logic
however if there is no user object
attached to it then it's going to return
an error saying
you know you're unauthorized to access
that you must log in
so let's create a new folder for our
middleware
and i'm going to just create a file
called auth middleware
and here we're going to create our
middleware i'm going to call this
protect
because it's going to protect a route
and ensure that the user is logged in to
actually access that endpoint
and with the middleware you get the same
thing as any other controller you get a
request response and then you also get
the
next object
and so here what we're going to do is
we're going to destructure out user
from our session and we're going to say
if
user does not exist which means you know
the user is not logged in because if
there's no user attached to the session
object
then we know the user is not logged in
we're just going to return a response
that says
first of all going to set the status to
41 and then we'll do json
and then here we'll say status fail
and then what we're going to do is we're
going to send a message that's going to
say unauthorized
however if the user is logged in then
we're just going to say next so when you
call the next
uh function then or the next method it's
going to then just send it to the
controller or the next middleware in the
stack
and one optional thing that you can do
and what i like to do is instead of
having all of the rest of our
uh routes get the user off of
rec.session.user
i'd rather have it attached directly to
the rec object
so i'm going to say rec.user
equals user so now if we ever want to
get the information regarding the user
we can just do rec.user instead of
having to go to rec.sessions.user
uh then we want to make sure we export
this
all right and so now under our post
routes which is the routes that we want
to protect let's
import our protect middleware
and to protect a specific route or
endpoint let's grab the post
method right here so this is going to be
when a user wants to create a new post
and all we have to do is just pass in
protect here so what's going to happen
is when a user hits this endpoint
we're going to run our middleware
function and our middleware function is
going to verify if the user is logged in
if he is logged in then we just call
that next method
which then goes straight to
postcontroller.createpost and then
and then all the logic for that gets run
however if he's not logged in
well our middleware is set to respond
and send a response back
and we call a return which means we
don't go through the rest of the
middleware or the
or the controller at the end we just
kill the signal and we send a response
back
so that's how authentication works uh
and so the last thing i want to do is
for index.js first of all i'm going to
change this back to 30 seconds
you can pick 60 seconds too actually
let's do
let's just do 60 seconds and let's save
everything
all right and what i want to do is first
of all
i'm going to log in let's delete all of
our previous cookies just to make sure
we don't have some kind of weird stale
state
and then let's log in so we'll log in
and you'll see that this is set to
expire in one minute that's in gmt i'm
in est so it's gonna expire in one
minute
but we're logged in so let's actually
create a new post
and let's hit send and it looks like we
are successfully able to create a post
however if we wait one minute for our
session to end
let's then try to see if we can create a
post and ideally we
should not be able to so i'll see you
guys back in one minute
all right so it's been about a minute
now let's test to see if we can still
create a post
so if i hit send again we should see
that it failed and it says we're
unauthorized
and that's because our session ended and
basically once your session ends you're
essentially logged out
so if we log back in it's going to
create a new session we're going to be
logged in for one minute
we can then create another post
all right so we've got our
authentication set up we can just decide
on what routes we want to protect
so you can use the same middleware uh
across your entire application so
for uh deleting or updating we can add
in protect as well
actually let's just add let's just add
it in for everything so even retrieving
post you have to be logged in
and you know for a real world
application you ideally want to
bump this up to something significantly
higher
um you know maybe a couple of hours or
something like that or even a couple
days
i'm going to keep this actually at 30
seconds just you know for testing
purposes so as we keep going with our
application i want to make sure that
authentication doesn't break for
whatever reason
and so from a express point of view
we're kind of done building an
application i know it's not like a
full-fledged application it was never
meant to be
i just wanted to have enough of an
application so that i can show you from
a docker perspective how everything
works
so uh this is all we're going to do i
know we don't have like a
logic to assign you know post to a
specific user
right now any user can create a post
edit any post and so it's just one big
global
list of posts but you know remember the
idea of this
this tutorial series is not about the
express application it's about docker so
we finished the express application side
of things we're going to get back to the
docker side of things uh in the next
video so we still got a ton of things to
learn
and we're also going to eventually move
on to getting all of this deployed to a
production setup and then show you guys
some of the challenges we face when
moving to a production environment
all right guys so before we proceed any
further i want to do a quick review of
the
architecture of our current application
and then i want to show you guys what i
ultimately want it to look like
once it's done so here i've got a little
diagram we've got our
in the blue so this big blue box this
represents our host machine so in this
case this is my windows machine
and so here we've got our express
application
that's listening on port 3000 and then
we've got our [ __ ] database which our
express application
can talk to on port 27017 and if we need
to actually send a request to our
express application then we just send a
a request to port 3000 to our local
machine it'll then get mapped to port
3000 of our
express application and so that's the
current architecture
and you know one of the things i wanted
to point out especially when we started
to add the [ __ ] database into our
application is that
we never opened up a port for our [ __ ]
database
right so just like we opened up port
3000 for our express server so that the
outside world can talk to it
we never did that for our [ __ ] database
and i actually did that on purpose
because
you know we definitely could open up a
port so that we can talk directly to the
[ __ ] database
so we could open up you know port 27017
on our local machine
or really any port really and then map
it to port 27017
uh to our [ __ ] container and that would
be perfectly fine
uh if you needed to talk to their manga
database however
i want you to think about what that
would ultimately mean because
now we're letting the outside world talk
to our [ __ ] database
right the only thing that actually needs
to talk to our [ __ ] database is our
express application
so there isn't really a need to open up
that port and it's also a little bit of
a
security vulnerability because your
database holds all of your critical
application data
it's got all of your user information
it's got all of their emails it could
have potentially other sensitive
information like social security number
passwords and other things like that so
generally it's best
not to make the [ __ ] container
accessible to the outside world
and i love how docker by default you
know if we don't open up any ports
it already isolates the [ __ ] container
so the outside world can't talk to it so
you can see that
just by running with docker we've
already added a little bit of security
to our application because
only our express application and our
containers
within that container within that
network that docker compose makes
can talk to that [ __ ] database no one
else can so
once again just to reiterate we aren't
going to open up any ports
to our [ __ ] database uh you know just
like in our docker compose file right
here
you can see we open up the ports for our
node app but there's no ports opened up
for [ __ ] so we're not going to open up
any ports
we're going to make it so that only our
application our express app our express
container
can talk to our [ __ ] database
and so like i said you know we're not
going to publish a specific port for our
[ __ ] database
just for security purposes and there's
really no reason to so
we're going to actually remove that and
so now what i want to talk about is
scaling up
our node containers so you know we
talked about passing in that scale flag
so that we can increase the number of
node containers that we have
so that we can handle an increased load
in traffic
so what we did was we would spin up
another node express container
which would then connect to our [ __ ]
database using the same exact port
and to be able to talk to this container
what we would have to do is publish a
different port
so the first node container you can see
that if we send a request to port 3000
it would get to map to port 3000 of the
first container
and then we'd have to grab a different
port on our local machine
like 3001 and so any traffic that gets
sent to
our local host on port 3001 we get
mapped 2.3 000
on our second node container and if we
wanted a third one we'd have to open up
another port like 3002 and so on so if
we had 50 containers
50 node apps we would need to open up 50
different ports
and you know like i said that's not a
scalable solution
you know our front end shouldn't have to
be aware of the number of
node containers that we're running on
our back end so
what we're going to ultimately do is
we're going to add
a load balancer so there's a couple of
different options that we have
uh you have things like hi proxy you've
got traffic and then you got nginx so
i'm going to walk you through how we can
do this with nginx and you'll see it's
really simple
and it's a good skill set to have
because you'll use nginx in other
scenarios outside of docker as well
it's a great web server as well so
ultimately
what our final architecture is going to
look like
is we're going to have a nginx container
and this nginx container is going to be
the entrance into our application so
we're no longer going to publish any
ports on our two node instances
so we're no longer going to open up port
3000.3001 on our local machine
instead we're going to publish one port
for our nginx container
and that port can be anything so we can
continue to use 3000 like we have
or we can pick any other port and you'll
see that you know when we get to
production we're just going to use port
80 because that's the default port for
http
as well as port 443 which is the port
for https
so we'll open up you know the port of
our choice on our local machine and
we're going to map it to port 80.
reason we map it to port 80 is because
that's the default port that nginx
listens on
technically that's fully customizable so
we can tell nginx
to listen on a different port but
there's no need for the extra
configuration i'd rather just leave it
to the default port so you know 3000
port 3000
gonna get mapped to port 80. and then
what our engine
is going to do is it's going to act as a
load balancer so every request that it
receives it's going to load balance it
to our two express instances and if we
have
four five one or a thousand instances
nginx will be able to
load balance all of those requests
across all of our
node instances and so this is a much
cleaner elegant solution because first
of all we only have to publish one port
and then nginx which is you know highly
efficient
is going to be able to ensure that all
of our node instances
are adequately um balanced with regards
to the number of requests that they
receive
all right and so that's all i wanted to
cover in this section so uh in the next
video we'll get started on adding that
nginx container
if you search for nginx on docker hub
you'll see the official nginx image as
the first result so this is the one that
we're going to use
and so let's get started on configuring
this first thing that we need to do is
i'm going to create a separate folder
for our nginx configuration i'm going to
call this nginx
and we're going to create one file and
that's going to be the default.com file
so this is just going to be a basic
configuration
for our nginx server
and within here we have to define a
server block and so this is all just
nginx specific configs nothing related
to docker
and here we'll just say our nginx server
is going to listen on port 80.
and then now this is where we actually
set it up to redirect
traffic to our express
or our node containers so we say
location
and then we provide a a url so this is
going to be the url of the request this
nginx server receives
uh and so here we could just do a slash
and then put in all of our configs
and then here we can say the most
important one is proxy
underscore pass and then here for the
proxy pass field we specify the url
of the servers that we want to uh you
know
proxy this traffic to so we want to send
this traffic to our
express application or our node
containers so
because our nginx server is also
a docker container that's going to be
running it has access to dns
so what we can do is we can type in http
colon
slash and then we can say node dash app
because remember
we have that uh custom network that was
created by docker compose
and so within our docker compose file we
can refer to any one of these services
by their name so if i call node app it's
going to load balance
between all of the node app containers
that we have
and then we have to make sure that we
send it on port 3000 because that's what
our express servers are listening on
now there's a couple of other properties
that we need to set
now because nginx is acting as a proxy
when we actually
proxy the original request to our
express application
the nginx server is going to strip off a
few details and
these details may actually be important
depending on what your application is
doing
and one of the things that nginx does is
uh you'll lose the
original ip address of the sender so
you know what was the ip address that
originated that request so we can tell
nginx to make sure that we forward that
along to our node applications now our
node application isn't actually making
use of that
but uh if you're doing any kind of like
rate limiting per ip address
these are all things that you want to
need so it's always a best practice to
configure this
and so to ensure that we pass on
the original sender's ip we do proxy
underscore set
underscore header and we do x
dash real ip
and then we do dollar remote
underscore addr all right and then
another thing that we want to do
is uh we're going to pass in another uh
another setting or flag
that's going to provide us a list
containing the ip addresses that every
server
the client has been proxied through so
this is another thing that's just best
practice
i i definitely recommend you read up on
nginx there's a lot of things that you
can do and configure
but i'm just trying to get you guys up
and running with the base configuration
and so i'm just going to copy this it's
a little bit of a long line
all right and so that's going to make
sure all of those um proxy server ips
are attached to the headers
and then we're going to add in just a
few other fields so we'll do proxy
underscore set underscore header
host and dollar sign http
underscore host
and then we're going to copy this again
and so that's all the configurations we
need however there's one minor tweak
that i want to do in this case
um basically all requests are going to
get forward to our node app
now you know for what we're doing we're
just building a back end however if you
wanted this nginx server to also handle
serving your front-end assets what you
would ultimately want to do
is in your api and we've already kind of
set this up is that
for all of your routes you want to make
sure that they are listening on
api v1
something so that way we know that the
nginx server can actually specify that
any request that starts with api is
meant for our backend
and then any request that's meant for a
url that does not have the api
um that's meant for our front end so
since all of these requests are
listening for
uh api first well except for this one
but we can add that real quick
uh what we can do is we can go back to
that configuration file and we can say
slash
api so in this case uh whatever
is uh whatever url is passed for
location this is going to specify
uh what the
request needs to look like for us to
forward it to our node application so
any request that comes in starting with
slash api we'll send it to our node app
and then anything that doesn't have
slash api right now it's just going to
drop
but in the future we could configure it
so that it can handle
um you know redirect that traffic to our
nginx
sorry not our engine but like a react
application or whatever our front end
application is
right now let's go ahead and go to our
docker compose file and let's
add our nginx service we can do nginx
and then the image uh this is going to
be nginx and then we can
let me put a space nginx and then i'm
going to grab the stable
alpine version
all right and so now um first of all we
no longer have to
publish ports for our node application
so we can remove that
actually and let's actually go into our
devonprod make sure we've removed any of
the ports being opened
there as well and doesn't look like we
have anything and prod looks okay
and so let's go back to our docker
compose
and then here let's open up our port so
we'll say ports
and then let's pick the port that we
want to publish so pick anything we can
do 3000 still if we want
and then we just want to make sure we
map it to port 80 because that's the
port that our nginx server is listening
on
and for production actually let's um i'm
going to copy this
for production it's going to be a
different port so instead of opening up
port 3000 we're going to open up
port 80. and we can remove that image
because we're not changing anything
and actually why even have this here i
can just copy this
and put this in the dev section
all right now the next thing that we
have to do is we have to get our
configuration file
that we built out into our nginx
container so there's a couple of
different ways we can do this
we can create our own custom nginx image
that already has our configuration built
in
or we can just configure a volume
specifically a bind mount and just have
it sync those
two files uh and so that'll i think
that's the route we're gonna go we're
just going to configure a bind mount
then we don't have to worry about
building a custom image and doing all of
that nonsense
so under volumes
uh so you have to understand a little
bit about where
uh nginx looks for this config so nginx
is going to look for this in the slash
etsy slash nginx slash conf
dot d slash default dot com file so
that's where it expects the
configuration
and we're going to sync that with uh
nginx default.com so we'll just go dot
slash
nginx slash default.conf
and then uh on the nginx container side
we're gonna make this
read-only it does it should never have
to change the configuration so a little
bit of a security check
and let's tear everything down
and let's build it back up we're just
going to do one instance just for now
let's just make sure everything's
working
and let's try sending a request so we're
going to try to log in again
and let's let's go to the body here
and it looks like we broke our
application
so let's take a look and see what
exactly we broke
alright guys so i made a stupid mistake
i just forgot to update this to port
3000
so i had left it at 3001 so make sure we
change that to 3000 because that's what
our engine x server is listening on so
now if i log
in we can see that it's successful and
we did receive the cookie
all right so it looks like we got our
application up into a working state
using nginx as a proxy so that i can
load balance requests to all of our
node instances but there's a couple more
things that we got to do so
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
pull up this web page right here so i
just want you to search for express and
then proxy and it'll be the first result
you get and it just explains that we do
have to add one extra configuration into
our express application
when whenever our express application is
sitting behind a proxy
and this isn't technically required for
our example
for our demonstration project but in a
production grade project you probably
will need to add this
um the configuration right here is this
app.set trust proxy
and so all this is saying is that we're
going to trust
some of the headers that our nginx proxy
is going to be adding onto the request
and so remember we configure our nginx
server to uh basically add the
originating
uh sender's ip address into the headers
so that if our express application does
need it
it has access to it all all we're doing
here is we're just
telling express to trust whatever our
nginx server is adding onto those
headers
uh so all we have to do is we have one
simple configuration so uh if we go to
our middleware we have our session
middleware so right above this
we're going to do app dot enable and
then we just say
trust proxy so that's the only thing
that we have to do but this is really
just in cases for
when you need access to that ip address
which we don't but if you're doing some
sort of rate limiting it can be
it's going to be necessary
so now that we get that done the last
thing that i want to do
is i want to scale up our application
again so i want to add a second
node instance so what we're going to do
is uh first of all i'm just going to
tear everything down
all right and then we're going to bring
everything back up um but this time
we're going to pass in the
the dash dash scale flag and we're going
to say node
app equals two so we have two instances
all right and the next thing i want to
do is uh you know in one of our routes
or one of our route controllers
i just want to do a console.log
and just have it say something it
doesn't matter say yeah it ran
the reason i want to do this is i want
to verify that nginx is actually load
balancing the request to all of our
nodes
all of our node instances so here i'm
going to create a new window
a new terminal actually and then i'm
going to split screen this so the window
on the left is going to represent
the logs for node instance one
the window on the right is going to
represent the logs for node instance 2.
so here i'm going to do a docker ps just
so i can grab the name and so i'm going
to say docker logs
i'll say no docker node app this will be
node app 1
dash for follow and i'm going to copy
this
and then paste that here and just change
this node app too
and so each time we send a request i
want to see a login generated here first
because of this console.log
and then ideally nginx should then send
the next request to this one and we
should see that log get generated here
so i'm going to change this to api v1
see if i could be a get request and
let's hit send
and i think i forgot to save it so let's
save this there we go
and now let's send the request all right
so we can see it said yeah it ran on the
left side so node app one
then let's run it again and so then we
can see it runs on node app two so it
looks like it's successfully load
bouncing let's just run it a couple more
times
to verify so ran on the left side right
on the right side
left right left right
left right
all right so we've got nginx up and
running i think that's a good stopping
point for this section
alright guys so there's one last thing
that i want to do
before we actually start moving to our
production server
and so i want to enable cores and if you
don't know what cores is it basically
just allows
your front end to run on one domain and
your
back end api to run on a different
domain because by default
let's say your front end is hosted at uh
you know www.google.com
right and let's say your front end sends
a request to
i don't say www.yahoo.com so let's say
yahoo.com
it's where our api exists well these are
two different domains by default our api
will reject that request from our front
end
so to allow these to be running on
different domains we have to configure
cores
so that different domains can access our
api um if you're running everything on
one domain then you don't need it but
i'm going to show you guys how to
configure that real quick it's really
simple
and so we're going to use this library
called cores and you'll see that
configuring is very easy
uh first of all uh we import cores and
then we just configure it as a
middleware that's it two lines of code
and you're good to go
so here i'm gonna do an npm install
cores
uh and so since we did add a new
uh package to our package.json file a
new dependency we're gonna have to
rebuild all
our image so here if we can do up
dash d dash dash build
so that's going to rebuild the image but
remember
by default when you run an up a docker
compose up
when you're already up and running if
you
have a anonymous volume like we do in
dockercompose.yaml
and we're using that for actually where
is it it's under dev
so we have this for our node modules
what's going to happen is if we run an
up when it's already up and running
it's going to use our old anonymous
volume that's going to have
only the node modules before we ran the
up command
and so to get the new course package
added in we need to make sure that we
pass in the dash dash
i actually have to figure out what it
was i have to run help to figure it out
we have to pass in the dash v
so that's going to recreate a new
anonymous volume so we'll do that
dash v
all right and so now if we go to our
index.js let's import the
course library
and then right here under app.enable
we'll just do app.use
and then we just pass in cores
and then here you have a config option
uh a config object that you can pass in
to kind of tweak the configuration for
course
we can just leave the default settings
and let's just test this out just to
make sure so
all right that worked not sure why it
took so long and then let's just make
sure we send it to
users login and let's see if this works
all right status success perfect alright
so guys so we are now good to go to
start deploying this to production so
now we're going to move on to deploying
our application into production
you're going to see in this section of
the tutorial series
we have a lot of things to cover still
so there's still a lot of things that we
need to learn about docker
a lot of best practices so in the
deployment section what's going to
happen is
i'm going to show you guys how to deploy
it and we're going to start off by doing
it the wrong way
and then we're going to slowly correct
each mistake one by one
so that you know exactly why we are
doing these things
and then when we get to our final uh
deployment scenario
where we actually deploy our application
the proper way and we
know how to properly update our
application you're gonna have a solid
understanding as to
why we are doing things the way that we
are
and uh so keep in mind for this
deployment section we do need access to
an a
to a ubuntu server and i don't really
care where this ubuntu server is running
you can run it on digitalocean like i'm
going to do
you can run it on aws as an ec2 instance
you can run it on gcp or azure as a
virtual machine
or you can just spin up virtualbox and
then run a ubuntu instance on your local
machine it doesn't really matter you can
follow along
and even if you can't i still recommend
you finish the rest of this video
because
we still have a lot more things to learn
and a lot more things to cover so don't
think that this is just about the
the final step and we just got a couple
more things to do and then we're done
with the video we still have a lot of
things to learn so
uh definitely stick to watching this
video even if you can't follow along
with all of the steps
all right so let's now get our ubuntu
server up and running and like i said
we're going to deploy this on
digitalocean as a droplet
however if you want to use a different
platform like aws or azure
or even run it as a virtual machine on
virtualbox on your on your local machine
feel free to do that as long as you have
an ubuntu server someplace
you should be able to follow along with
everything that i do
um but i'm going to specifically do this
on digitalocean so if you guys want to
see these
exact steps to do this on digitalocean
it's pretty straightforward as well
so i'm going to click get started with
the droplet and then here i'm going to
select ubuntu 20.04
we'll select the basic plan and then we
want to select regular intel with ssd
because it's cheaper
and then we select the cheapest option
that we can find and then by default
because i'm on the east coast it's going
to default to the new york data center
just pick whichever data center is
closest to you geographically
and then we want to select our password
so put in your password here
then we just hit create droplet
and so we'll let this run for a couple
minutes
um it does take some time for
digitalocean to spin up a new vm
and then once that gets started we'll
then install docker we do need to
install docker on our production
environment because
that's how our application runs
obviously
um so i'll see you guys about i'll see
you guys so i'll see you guys in a
minute or so
all right so our droplet was created we
can see our public ip address so let's
copy that
and i'm going to open up my terminal
make this bigger for you guys and then
here we just do ssh root
at and then that ip address and then
we're going to say yes
and then put in our password
all right and so now we're logged in
and the first thing that we have to do
is get docker installed
and so there's a couple of different
ways to do this so if you pull up the
documentation for installing docker
engine on ubuntu
they've got some very easy steps to go
through it's just a couple of commands
however there's an even easier method so
if you go to get.docker.com
right here there's actually a script
that's uh on this hosted on this website
that actually installs
docker for you automatically so you just
have to run one command
so here under this section right here
you just copy this curl command
and so all you have to do is copy that
paste it in here
and then what that's going to do is it's
going to download a file called
getdocker.sh
and then we can just say sh get dash
docker.sh and so that's going to run
through all the steps for getting docker
and it's really just running the same
exact steps here but
this just requires two commands so i
think it's a little easier and that's
the route that i'm gonna go
all right so it looks like it's
completed let's verify that docker was
installed by doing a docker
dash dash version and we can see that it
spits out a version which means docker
was successfully installed
now this only installs docker if you try
to do docker dash compose
dash v to get the version uh looks like
docker compose is not installed by
default so let's get that installed
let's pull up the directions
so we'll say docker compose install
ubuntu and then here we can just select
linux here
and we just copy this command
paste it in there
and then copy this command
so now if we do docker dash compose
dash b we should see it return a version
all right and so now we've got uh docker
installed on our ubuntu machine
in the next video let's set up a git for
our application so that we can store our
application
uh in a git repository and then we can
pull it into our production server
all right so let's get started on
creating a git
repo for our application so on logged
into github
we're gonna hit this plus sign and we're
gonna select new repository we'll give
it whatever name we want i'm just gonna
call this node docker
and then you can make it public or
private but for practice i'm just going
to leave it as public
we'll create repository and it's going
to give us a couple of commands to run
to initialize it
so i'll walk you through that i'm not
going to follow those exactly
so we're going to do git actually before
we get started first of all let's create
a git ignore file
so we'll say dot get ignore
and we want to make sure that we don't
uh include our node modules files
because we don't actually need those in
our git repo
because we can just copy all of our
source code and then just do an npm
install
and then based off the dependencies that
we have listed in our package.json
uh basically node will know exactly what
uh packages to install so
we don't ever need to actually push all
of our node modules into github
so we just say node underscore modules
slash that's all save that we'll do a
git
init then we'll do a git add
dash dash all so it's going to add all
files
and then we want to copy this git branch
dash
m actually we'll do a git commit first
i will do git commit dash m
first commit
and then we'll do git branch m
and then finally we'll copy these last
two lines right here
gonna set the remote repository and then
we want to push those changes to our
repository
all right so all of our changes should
get pushed out and so if you just
click on this link right here you should
see all of your files and everything
looks good
and so in the next section we're going
to make a few we're going to make a
couple of
changes to our uh
our docker configs for production so
that it's ready
to get deployed for our production
server all right now let's open up our
source code and let's go to our docker
compose
dev and so you'll see here that there's
a couple of environment variables that
we need
in our application for it to work right
so first of all we need the [ __ ] user
the [ __ ] password in our node app
and then we also need our session secret
and then under our [ __ ] server we need
a couple of things so we need the root
user and then the root password so
here we are hard coding it into our
dockercompose.dev
file because this is our development
environment and so i these are all just
for practice and for tests but you
definitely don't want to accidentally
um push any of your production
secrets or configs or passwords into
github right because if we put our
our environment variables all here then
all of our production passwords and
secrets
would automatically get pushed into
github so the way around this
is what we're going to do is we're going
to get all of those environment
variables
from the machine the sir that docker is
running on so from this ubuntu machine
we're going to actually configure the
environment variables and then from
there
docker will know what those values are
docker will pull all those usernames
those passwords
those root users those root passwords
from our host ubuntu
machine and so from a configuration
perspective right
here we have all of these environment
variables i'm going to copy this
and we're going to tweak something so
under environment
we already have it right here actually
we're gonna paste this
we don't need the development one
anymore because we're in production
and so instead of hard coding into
whatever our production username is and
our production password is
what i'm going to do instead is i'm
going to just make one minor change i'm
going to put a dollar sign
then brackets remove this
and then say [ __ ] underscore user
and so what exactly is this saying it's
saying that the environment variable
called
[ __ ] user is going to pull this value
from an environment variable named [ __ ]
user on our ubuntu machine
so if we define an environment variable
on this abundant machine
called [ __ ] user then docker will be
able to pull it from there
and so that way we never have to
actually store our passwords in
our docker file so we don't need to
worry about it accidentally getting
pushed up into github
and so i'm going to change this as well
and we're going to change the session
secret as well
and then we're gonna have to define the
same thing for our [ __ ] service
and we can see here we have this these
two values right here so we're just
going to copy this
paste it in there and then do the same
thing here
all right and i want to quickly show you
how we set an environment variable
on a linux machine it's actually really
easy all you need to do is we type in
export
and then the name of the environment
variable so let's say as an example we
set session secret right
we can set session secret equal to
some arbitrary value and i'll just say
maybe hello
and then if we do print nv so this
command right here this is going to
print out all of our
environment variables so let's see if we
can see our session secret and then we
can see our session secret
is set to hello so this value will then
get pushed
into this variable right here which will
then get assigned as an environment
variable into our docker container and
so that's how we're going to handle
environment variables
within our uh production and
for our production server all right so
now let's get the rest of our
environment variables onto our
production machine
so we could go one by one and just say
you know export
uh and then you know [ __ ] underscore
init db and so on and just uh
configure all of those manually however
that's kind of a slow process
and on top of that it won't actually
persist across reboot so
i want to show you my method of getting
our environment variable set
on our machine uh that'll actually
persist through reboots if the switch
goes down comes back up it's
automatically going to load all of our
environment variables
and so the first thing that i want to do
is i want to create an environment file
that
is going to store all of our environment
variables so here i'm under my root
folder
i'm just going to make that file store
that file here
i'm not saying you should be doing
anything under the root user
you know i don't want to go into all of
the security best practices you probably
shouldn't be doing anything as a root
user
but i want to keep this video as simple
as possible so pick a location
in your system uh the location doesn't
matter the only thing that i would
recommend is don't put this anywhere
near
where your application code is going to
get stored and so that way you don't
accidentally ever push this up into git
that's the only thing that matters so
i'm going to store it under slash root
and i'm going to say dot env so vi.env
that's going to create our environment
file
and then here we just store all of our
environment variables
uh and so i'm just going to grab them
from the dev file right here
and we just copy the same exact syntax
so
this is going to be where we're going to
set this to prod of course
and then the last two are going to be
the ones for [ __ ]
and that's all we need to do so we've
got our environment file
uh then if i do a pwd make sure you're
in your root folder and if i do an ls
minus la
this is going to show us this profile
file so we're going to open that up
and i'm going to go to the absolute
bottom of that file
and i'm going to create a simple config
right here
i'm going to say set dash o
all export and then source
and then we want to provide the path to
that environment file so that's going to
be
root dot env
and then we say set plus o
i'll export all right and so what's
going to happen
is that it's going to loop through
all of those environment variables that
we set and it's going to set them
on this machine
let's save that
and these changes won't take effect
until we
close out our terminal session and
reopen it so i'm going to just exit out
of here
and take me back to my local machine i'm
going to ssh back in again
and now i want to do a print nv and
let's make sure all of our environment
variables are set
so we've got our [ __ ] password perfect
we've got our [ __ ] root user
uh let's just i believe it should be
actually let's just see uh
if i do a cat.env there's a one two
three four
five six so we have six of them so this
is one
right here two three four
five and then
6. all right so we've got all of our
environment variables set uh you know
i'm not saying this is the best method
you can use whatever method you want
some people don't like having a file on
their machine with all their passwords
uh they they may use some other method
of assigning secrets so
use whatever method you prefer i'm just
showing you guys one example of how to
do that
all right so uh we've made some changes
to our docker compose file in the last
video
when we assigned these environment
variables to be whatever was set on the
ubuntu server
uh and so uh what we need to do is we
need to add these to git so we'll do a
git
add dash dash all actually first of all
let's make sure i save it
it looks like uh i guess we pushed those
changes after we made that i don't think
we did but let's just say git commit
dash m uh env changes
okay so there we go so we made a couple
of changes
and then we want to do a git push
and then let's go back to our git repo
and let's open up my dockercompose.prod
file let's just make sure the updates
got taken
and it looks like they did so perfect so
now that we have our
final application code within git let's
go to our production server
and let's uh first of all let's create a
a folder to store our application so i'm
going to create a folder called app
and a cd into app
and then we're going to click we're
going to clone our git repo so
copy this i'm going to say
git clone and then clone it into our
current directory
and so now if i do an ls we should see
all of our application files
and so now just like we did on our local
machine
let's uh run a docker compose up and
let's see if this works on our
production server
we're going to say docker dash compose
and then we're gonna say dash f and then
we'll do docker dash compose
dot yaml and then dash f and then docker
dot compose dot prod dot yaml
we'll say up with the d flag
and because there's no images already on
this machine because we just installed
docker
it should automatically build our node
image as well so let's run that
and i realized i made a mistake so you
can see here
uh this should be indented one slot back
i'm not sure what happened in my
production example but that got a little
rearranged so just move that over and
that's why he was saying that there was
an error on that specific line so we got
that fixed
now unfortunately we have to do a get
add again
and then a git commit
and then i get push
and then we go back to our server and we
can just do a git pull
alright and so now we've got those
changes and now let's run that same
command
alright so it's building our image
perfect
right and now it looks like it's
finished let's do a docker ps
uh we can see that we've got all of our
containers up and running
and now let's go ahead and actually just
send a request to our server so
i'm going to pull up the ip address of
my
note of my uh digitalocean droplet
and then let's go back to postman and
i'm going to just create a new request
so go to http colon slash put that ip in
uh we don't need to put in the port
because it's listening on port 80 so you
could do that but it's the default
and then here we want to go to slash api
slash v1 slash
uh let's just get that one let's just
see if that works all right and we can
see it says hi there so it looks like
things are working
but i also want to log in so we'll do uh
users
log in well actually we have to do sign
up because remember
we deployed uh this on a different
server so there's nothing in our
database so we have to actually sign up
first
and let's set our body we'll do raw then
json and then here we'll say username
sanjeev and then we'll say password
password and this is going to be a post
request
all right and it looks like that works
so it looks like i think
it's pretty safe to say that our
application is now working in our
production environment
and everything has been deployed
properly
all right so now we have successfully
deployed our application to our
production server and we can start
receiving and handling production
traffic um but how exactly do we go
about
uh pushing out changes to a production
server you know let's say that a
developer on our team
either made some code changes or maybe
even added a new feature
how do we get those changes that we
implemented in our development
environment pushed out to our production
environment
well let's walk through the different
steps that's going to be required
so the first thing is i'm going to make
a simple code change so under this dummy
route that we have in our index.js file
i'm just going to add a few exclamation
points like i've done before
so let's save that and the first thing
that we have to do is we need to push
that out to github
all of these changes need to be pushed
out to our repository so let's do a git
add dash dash all and then we do a git
commit
we'll commit those changes and then
we'll do a git push
all right so those got pushed out to
github let's just double check to see if
those changes are there so i'm going to
select the index.js file
and if we take a look at our route we
can see we have the extra exclamation
points
all right so now we have to go to our
production server it looks like i lost
connectivity so let me log back in
make sure you use cd into your app
directory and so here we need to
pull in those new changes so we have to
pull in the updated code so we just do a
git pull
and so once you do a git pull it should
update that index.js file and if i do a
cat
index.js we should see those changes
take effect and we can see that here
all right and so now because this is our
production environment it's not going to
automatically
sync our code or anytime our code
changes we don't have nodemon to restart
application
we have to rebuild an image uh and
create brand new containers
so we have a couple of different options
you know we can do a docker compose
and then down and then after that we do
a docker compose
up or we can just do a docker compose up
and i prefer just doing a docker compose
up because it's a little bit quicker
because the system
or docker compose will actually delete
the container and spin up a new
container
whereas when we do down it tears
everything down and then until we
run the up command it's going to keep
everything down so when you do down and
then up
you face a little bit more of an outage
so let's do docker compose and then
let's pass in our files as usual
and then let's do uh up and then dash d
so let's see if this updates our code
all right and so we could see here it
looks like docker compose detected that
the [ __ ] database
is already up to date we don't need to
change anything and that's expected
because we didn't change anything with
that
same thing with the redis same thing
with nginx however for some reason it
did not update our node app right it
says it's already
up to date and remember that's because
docker compose
is very dumb right it just checks to see
if there's an image
named that it does not know that this
image is out of date so what we have to
do is
we have to run the same command with the
dash dash build
so let's run that and this should
rebuild the image
and then since the image has changed
docker compose is going to have to
delete the old container
and spin up a new node container
and so you can see here it's now
recreating that container because the
image changed
and it noticed that you know [ __ ]
didn't change once again we just didn't
change
and nginx didn't change so if any one of
those properties for any of these
containers had changed
as well then it would update those as
well all right so the changes are done
and uh let's go to our uh our postman
and then let's send a request to that
route so let's hit send
and we can see that we got a response
back with the extra exclamation points
so we have now successfully pushed out
changes to our production server
however there's a couple of things i
didn't like so first of all when you do
this
up dash d build it's going to check
all of your containers all of your
services to see if anything's changed
now in our application we know the only
thing that's going to be changing
whenever we change our source code
is going to be our node app container so
is there any way that we can tell
docker compose to not even bother
checking these things because
you know we don't want to accidentally
maybe we put in a typo into our compose
file and then we actually change
uh some settings in our [ __ ] database
and that causes our [ __ ] database to go
down
and then have to get rebuilt and then we
suffer an even bigger outage
how can we tell docker compose to only
rebuild our node app and then recreate
that container
and then here what we can do is we can
specify the service name so i could just
say node
app and that's just going to rebuild our
node app server service let's test this
out and see if this actually works
and so it rebuilt our node app service
and that's good so we built that image
however once again it went and checked
to see if
[ __ ] and as well as our other redis
container probably somewhere in there
needed to be updated so why exactly did
it check that
actually it looks like it just checked
for [ __ ] so why did it check to see if
our [ __ ]
database was up to date well despite the
fact that we provided the
service here just as node app what
happens is if you take a look at our
configuration and go to our docker
compose.yaml file
you'll see our node app is dependent on
[ __ ]
so within docker compose anytime you
specify
a service and you need to rebuild that
service it has no idea if all of its
dependencies
changed and when i say dependencies i
mean under the depends on so
it has to rebuild the [ __ ] container
because it has no idea if the changes
will impact
mango or not so that's the reason why
that's happening and there's a way
around that
what we can do is we can pass in one
more flag
we can pass in the dash dash
no dash depths so we're basically saying
no dependencies
so we're not going to rebuild that [ __ ]
dependency as well so if we run this now
you can see that it successfully builds
our image
and then it rebuilds our container
uh and you can see it's already up today
because we didn't make any code changes
so let's test this out one more time
let's push out some changes
so i'm going to go to my index.js i'm
going to delete this
i'm going to save that i'm going to do a
git add
and then we'll do a git push
changes have been pushed let's do a get
pull
and then let's run this same exact
command and let's just hope that
only our node container gets rebuilt
and recreated
all right so it recreated our container
and so now if i
uh send a request to that route we can
see that we don't get exclamation points
now there may be an instance where maybe
you just want to rebuild a container
let's say we didn't make any
code changes uh the image hasn't changed
and we just want to
rebuild a container for whatever reason
uh there's a couple of specific flags
that we need to pass in so let's do a
docker compose up
dash d and let's say we want to rebuild
the node app service
if we do this well here's the problem
here's the problem right none of the
images change so if we just run this
it's not going to
rebuild it because it's going to say
that it's up to date so what we can do
is if i do a dash dash help
and i need to place that here
we can do the force recreate so this
will recreate containers even if their
configuration
and images haven't changed so let's try
that out
we'll just say dash dash force recreate
and we'll say node app so let's see if
this recreates our node container
and two things happen well first of all
it recreated our [ __ ] container
that's not good and then it recreated
our node app so remember it recreated
our
[ __ ] container because in our docker
compose file we say it depends on manga
so because it depends on it
we got to rebuild that also uh and so to
get around that
just like we did before we can pass in
the no depth
argument so we can say no dash depths
and this is going to trigger a rebuild
of that container
and no other containers
so i want to quickly summarize our
overall development to production
workflow
and i want to quickly reiterate how we
actually push changes
uh from our development environment to
our production environment
so whenever we make any kind of change
to our code base
the first thing that we do is we push it
out to github and then once we push it
out to github
our production server will log in and
then we'll do a git pull which is going
to pull
that new code base in and then once we
get the updated code
what we're going to do is we're going to
run the docker compose up dash dash
build
and that's going to trigger a rebuild of
the node
image and then once we build the image
we can then rebuild a brand new
node container using that new node image
so there's a couple of different issues
with this
development to production workflow and
the main issue is that we're building
our image
on our production server this is
something that is never recommended you
should never be building your image on
your production server
and that's because building an image
takes resources
it takes a cpu cycles and it takes
memory
and for our application it's obviously a
tiny demo application so it doesn't
take that much cpu horsepower to
actually build that image but as your
application grows
right it's going to require larger and
longer build times
and so you know as that application
grows you're going to see that when you
build an image it's going to take more
cpu and it's going to take more memory
so if you do this on a production server
you could end up starving
your actual production traffic because
all of the compute power
and all of your memory is going towards
building an image
and your production server should only
be meant for one thing and that is just
to handle production traffic it should
never be doing anything else
so what i ultimately want to do is move
away from this development workflow
and work move towards a workflow that
allows us to build an
image on a machine that's not a
production server
so let's take a look at the production
workflow that we're ultimately going to
move to
all right so in this workflow uh the
main idea is
that we're no longer going to build that
image on our production server
so what's going to happen is the
engineer on the left he's going to build
an image
on his dev server so he builds it on his
dev server using a docker
compose up dash dash build and so that's
going to trigger a build on his local
machine
once that's done he's going to push that
brand new built
image to docker hub so docker hub is
just a repository of images
you can use any docker repository it
doesn't have to be docker hub
you can use amazon's repo repository
um but you know when we demo this we're
just gonna use docker hub because it's
free
so we'll push that image to docker hub
and then our production server
we're gonna do a we're going to pull
that brand new node image
so we're pulling in the finalized image
with all of the new code changes
and then all we have to do is do a
docker compose up
docker compose is going to detect that
there's a brand new image for our node
container or our node service
and that's going to trigger a rebuild of
the node container using the brand new
node image
so this is the workflow that we are
going to move towards
and you can see that by building it on
the dev server we no longer have to
build it on our production server
so next video we're going to actually go
ahead and implement this and i'm going
to show you guys
how much better of a workflow this
actually is
all right so to implement our new
workflow the first thing that we have to
do is create an account on docker hub
so if you haven't already done that go
ahead and sign up to docker hub
and then sign in so i'm going to log in
real quick
and so once we've logged in this is
going to be uh you know where we store
all of our repositories so i'm going to
create a brand new repository
and i'm going to give this name node app
and i'm going to make this public so
docker hub gives you one public repo
sorry you get unlimited public
repositories you get one private
repository so i'm just gonna keep that
as public for now
and then we'll hit create
and so now let's uh push our
image that we have on our development
server up to this repository so this
repository can store
our final image and so to do that the
first thing that you have to do is let's
go to our
development environment and let's do a
docker and then there's a command called
push and let's just do
help just to kind of poke around and see
what options we have so it looks like we
just do docker
push and then we just do the name
and then you know kotlin and then tag
so if we do docker well first of all
let's do docker image
ls
and let's grab our latest docker image
for our node app which is this one right
here so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to do a docker
push and then this and then if i don't
pass in
you know specific tag it's just going to
assume to be latest so let's try that
and we may have to do a docker login
first
all right so we're logged in let's try a
push again and let's see if that worked
and it looks like it's denied
and so the reason for this is that uh
when you push an image
to docker hub it needs to have a very
specific name
so if we go here this is the name of our
repository this is the name that we have
to push it at so we have to do sloppy
networks which is my username
so you have to use your username
whatever that is and then slash
and then the name of the image so we're
going to change that so how do we change
the name of an image because right now
if i look at my image
it's called this and you can see i need
to rename it to something like
sloppy networks slash node app
uh so to do that we have to do the
command
docker image and then there's a command
called tag
all right and so what we do is you grab
the name of your current image that you
want to rename
and then you want to then pass in the
name that you want to rename it to what
it actually does is it copies the image
and then gives the new copied image the
name that you tell it so i'm going to
name this
my username make sure you put in your
username
slash and then we'll just say what was
it called
node app
and now if i do a docker image ls
scroll to the top we can see that we now
have sloppy networks slash
node app and it's got a tag of play just
because we didn't give it a tag
so let's push this up now so let's do a
docker push
copy that name
and so now we can see that it's
successfully getting pushed
all right so now that that's complete if
we go back to docker hub and refresh
this page
we should see that an image was
successfully pushed and so we can see
that we got an image that was pushed a
few seconds ago
uh and so now it's within this
repository and our production server
can pull that image
however before our production server can
actually pull this image we need to tell
docker compose
that we want to actually use this image
for our application moving forward
so how do we do that right because we
still need to be able to build
the uh build our image ourselves with
docker compose but we also need to be
able to tell it that you know when we
want to actually run the application we
want to use this specific image in this
repository
so what we have to do is let's go to
dockercompose.yaml
and under node app what we can do is we
can pass
under here an image property and here
you just pass in the name of that repo
so you do sloppy
networks slash node app so once again
your username
and then the name of the project
and so now when you do a docker pull
it's going to pull this specific
image and you can still technically
build an image as well so you get the
flexibility of being able to build an
image
as well as pulling the image from the
repository
now since we made some changes to our
docker compose file we do need to push
that to github and then pull those
changes
onto our production server so let's go
ahead and do that right now
i'm going to do a git add dash dash all
and then on our production server we
just do a git pull
all right so now what i want to do is
let's go ahead and do a docker compose
up
dash d and let's just see what happens
all right so it rebuilt an image just
because um
now our image is actually called sloppy
networks slash node app so when we
actually build an image
it's by default going to give this name
so it built that image
uh on the production server local
machine it named it sloppy networks
slash node
uh dash app colon latest and then it
recreated the
application and nothing's changed so
we've got it working now
um but how exactly do we push those
changes now so let's say
uh in our development environment we
make some code change so let's go back
to
index.js and let's make some changes
i'm going to add some exclamation points
so how do i actually push those changes
right
well remember what we want to do is we
want to build an image
on our local machine and then push it up
to uh
our uh our repository on docker hub
and then once it's pushed out to a
repository we'll then pull it onto our
production server
so how do we build an image well we
already know how to build an image
however we can use docker compose to do
that as well
so let's see if i can find the command
so we'll do docker
dash compose and you gotta do the dash f
and everything again so we'll do docker
dash compose
dot yaml and then uh dash f once again
and then docker dash compose dot
prod dot yaml so we always want to do
the dot prod because we're building the
image for production
and we want to run instead of up right
if we do help we can actually do a build
so just like when it comes to docker um
like docker build
or docker push and things like that we
have all the same commands for docker
compose so we want to do
docker compose build that's going to
build all of our services
so we'll do build and what this is going
to do is
for all the services that you have and
it looks like my terminal just crashed
wonderful
and do i still have and it's gone so i
gotta rebuild that for a sec so give me
one second
and then we do build
so what this is going to do is uh if we
go to our docker compose it's going to
look through all of our services
that allow us to build an image right
and so right now we only have one custom
service where we have to build an image
however if we had more than one uh maybe
we had a couple of other
uh services that required building
images it would build the image for all
of those services so if i do build now
right it's going to go through that
whole process
it's built the image if i do a docker
image ls
you can see we have a sloppy network
slash node app and you can see this one
was built five seconds ago so this is
the one that we're concerned with
and so now that we have this image we
can then push it up to
uh docker hub however one thing i want
to point out like i said it's going to
build all of our services
and in this case it's just our one node
app service because we only have one
service where we can build a custom
image
however in a production application you
may have more than one service so let's
say we only wanted to build
uh the image for just one of our
services
is there any way we can specify that
absolutely all you have to do is just
pass in the name
at the end of the service that you want
to build for so here this is only going
to build the node app service
all right so we got our image the next
thing we have to do is push the docker
hub
so just like we have a build command we
also have a push command so we can say
push
and this is going to push it to docker
hub and you have the option of pushing
all of your images for all of your
services which
if i just hit enter right now it's going
to do that or we can also specify just
the services we want to push an image
for so if i do no dash app
it's only going to push the image that
we built for this service but if we have
more than one service then we could
theoretically
push all of them out if we just don't
specify the name of a service
so i'm going to just push out just this
service
and remember the change that we made was
we added the extra exclamation points
all right so we push that image we go
back to docker hub
hit refresh
and you can see once again it was pushed
a few seconds ago
and if you wanted to see all of them
it's going to show you that but let's go
back
and now let's go to our production
server
and instead of running it up we just do
a dash dash help
and let's see if there's a option to
pull
an image all right so now if we take a
look at the list it looks like there is
a way to pull a service image so let's
try that
i'm going to say pull
and let's see what happens
all right so it looked like it pulled
all of our images so it it went back to
docker hub and checked to see if there
was a
more recent redus image same thing with
nginx same thing with [ __ ]
and then it pulled our brand new node
app image so if i do a docker image ls
uh you'll see that this one was created
about three minutes ago
um i guess it didn't have to update this
but i'm not sure why that didn't get
updated but let's let's try it out
anyways
uh and so what we're gonna do is let's
do a docker compose
up now with the new image
and just pass in dash d and let's let it
run
so we checked to see if these images
were up to date and they were
and it looks like we were running an
older image so now that we got the new
image it's going to rebuild
our container
and now it's running our latest image so
if i hit send
we can see that it now has the
exclamation points all right so it looks
like we now have somewhat of a better
a development to production workflow by
pushing and pulling images
um but a couple of things to note so
first of all it checked to see if all of
these images were up to date
um you know there may be times where we
don't want to pull the latest image for
those
so just like we did before we can do up
dash d
and then we can say dash dash no dash
depths
and then we can specify we just want to
uh
we just want to specifically update the
node app
so in this case it's just going to try
and update the node app in this case
all right so let's run through this
workflow one more time
just to make sure you guys understand
what we have to do so let's go back to
our
our development environment i'm going to
change this back to here by removing
those
and so the first thing that we have to
do is once we make those changes we have
to build an image so we run a docker
compose
build right and we have the option to
specify just one service or more than
one service or all services
i'm just going to specify this one
service we'll hit enter it's going to
build that image
next thing we have to do is we have to
push this brand new image that we
created to docker hub
and so we can do a let me hit the up
arrow a couple of times
so then we do a docker compose push
and once again we can push all of our
images or just one image so in this case
we're going to push just the node app
image so let's run that
it's going to push it up to docker hub
all right and so now once that's pushed
up there let's go to our production
server
and then here we pull that brand new
image
so we do a pull and here you can also
specify just the
service that you want to pull an image
for so i'm going to specify just the
node app because that's the only thing
we're updating
and so now it's going to pull our node
up
and then we can run a docker compose up
and specify just the services we want to
change so if we run just an up
this is going to try and uh it's going
to check to see if there's changes for
any of our services and if there are
it's going to change all of those
services however we didn't change
anything with our databases so nothing
technically needs to change but
in a production environment if you know
nothing should change um just
you know i would just rather just hard
code it to say i only want to update my
node or express app just in case because
i don't want to accidentally
rebuild a database or my redis data
store
or any other important aspect of my
application that doesn't need updating
so i'm going to pass in the dash dash no
dash depths and then specify node app so
that we only
can rebuild just that one service
all right so we're recreating the
container because we're using a brand
new image that we pulled
once that's done let's test it out and
so now the exclamation points should be
gone
and now they're gone so that's our
development workflow
at the moment uh in the next video i'm
going to show you how we can automate
one of those steps
and you'll see that um you know i'm not
saying that you do want to automate that
specific step that we're going to do
um but it is an option i just want to
make sure i cover everything in this
video
so in the last video i walked you
through how we can implement our new
development workflow by pushing
and pulling images and one of these
steps
we can actually automate so uh you know
when we push a new image
to docker hub wouldn't there be wouldn't
it be cool if there was a nice way to
have the production server
automatically detect that we pushed a
new image and pull that new image well
there is a tool that we can use called
watchtower
that will automatically check docker hub
periodically for a new image
and whenever an image gets pushed it'll
automatically pull it to
your production server and then restart
a your container with the brand new
image
now some people you know like this
feature
some people don't right some people
don't like to
automatically push out changes to their
production server because you know they
want to mainly do it to manually do it
so that they can verify that everything
runs okay because you don't want it to
accidentally pull an image
and then you know have it potentially
crash out with some error logs
while you're not there at the command
line so uh you know some people like it
some people don't but i did want to show
you guys how we can automate that step
so here in google i'm just going to
quickly search for docker
watch tower
and so here this is the github page for
this
and what we want to do is just go to the
full documentation page
and this is going to have a quick start
for you so it's going to show you how to
actually use this feature but it's a
special container that'll just
periodically watch docker hub
for a specific image and if it sees a
new image get pushed out it's going to
pull that image automatically for you
and restart the container so it's a
container that handles the automation of
your other containers
and there's plenty of documentation but
i'm just going to show you guys how to
run this real quick
and let's go to our production server so
let's do docker ps
you can see all the containers we have
and that's just for application and
we're gonna do is we're gonna do a
docker run
dash d there's gonna be a lot of flags
by the way so let's give this container
a name so i'm gonna say name
a watchtower
then we're going to pass in some flags
some environment variables so we're
going to
call this watchtower underscore trace
and if you're wondering where i'm
getting these you know just take a look
at the documentation so
you can see under arguments i think it's
under here you'll see all of the
environment variables if i search for
trace
so it's going to show us you know this
is just going to include trace mode with
verbose logging so i like having extra
logs
and then we're also going to pass in the
poll interval so this is going to tell
us how long we how frequently
we should pull docker hub
so watch tower underscore trace is going
to be set to true if you do want the
trace on or you can set it to false
then we're going to pass in one more
environment variable called watchtower
underscore debug equals true
and then one more this is going to be
watch tower
underscore pull underscore interval
this could be set to 50. i think that
should be every 50 seconds we should
check for a new image
and then we have to set up this volume
uh so this has just come straight from
the documentation
so we do slash var run
slash docker dot sock
and then call in slash var
slash run slash docker dot sock
and that should not be in all capitals
by the way
and then we have to specify the image so
the image
just comes from that repository but if
you look at the
home homepage you can see that the image
is just container slash watch tower
that's container with three r's by the
way
all right so now if we do a docker ps
we've got our new
container it's running and let's just do
a docker
logs and then just grab this container
and then pass in the dash f flag
all right so it looks like it's running
the list of
retrieved containers and i realized i
made a mistake so
there's a uh the one important thing
that we have to pass into this docker
run command
is the list of services that we actually
want to watch because right now
it doesn't know which services we want
to watch so let me stop this
and let me just do a docker rm
and then we'll just use a dash f flag to
delete it
and then we're going to run that long
command again but here we have to
specify the services
or the containers that we wanted to
watch out for
so in this case we have this app node
app1
so we wanted to make sure that there's
that if a new image gets pushed for this
container
to you to docker hub that it
automatically pulls it
right so you can specify as many
different containers as you want so i'm
just going to use just this one
and then now let's do a docker logs
watch
all right so now retrieve running
containers and then
basically nothing's happening except
it's saying that a check will be
performed in 49 seconds
uh so let's um make a change to our code
and push an image
so i'm going to add quotations and then
some extra
fun stuff we're going to do the two
usual steps we're going to do a build
and then we're going to do a push
and then let's take a look at the logs
and let's see um
if after the time limit after the 50
seconds it does successfully detect that
there's an image
and it rebuilds our container and look
at that something happened what happened
let's see uh so this is where we were
all right then it's checking so the 50
seconds end is going to check for
containers for updated image
it's retrieved the running containers
all right trying to load authentication
credentials no credentials for sloppy
networks found
and we were still able to get an image
right so this remember this is the
reason why it's checking for credentials
is because
there's a possibility that one of my
images or one of my containers uses a
image from a private repository so if it
did
use a image from a private repository we
would have to make sure
that we just did a docker login right so
it would look like
docker login and you would just do this
on your production server
and then you know if you aren't logged
in it's going to actually ask for
credentials so let me log out just to
show you what that looks like
so now if we do a docker login you would
then put in your username
and i already messed that up
and then your password so if you have if
you are using a private repository
make sure to do that on your production
server so that your production server
can actually access it
but so we don't actually need it not a
big deal because it's a public
repository
we got the image that our container is
using so our container is using sloppy
network slash node app
we're checking if pull is needed so now
it's basically querying docker hub
and then it's going to do a few other
things a few other things
a few other things i guess with like
authentication and a few other things
like that
uh right so then it says it's determined
that there is a new image so it's going
to do a pull so it's pulling the new
image
uh then it stopped our container it's
deleting our container it's creating a
brand new container
it's then starting the new container
right and then after 50 seconds it's
going to do all of the
same stuff over again
all right so let's test this out so
remember we we didn't do anything this
was all automated
so if i hit send
you could see all the changes that got
pushed out so we've automated
that last final step in our development
to production workflow
where we pull the image into our
production server and we're letting our
production server automatically do it
for us
using this watchtower container and
let's just test it out just to make sure
that it works fully again
so i'm just going to delete these
i'm going to do a docker build
and then let's do a docker push
and you can see during the last run it
said no new images were found so
uh you know it's it's pretty smart at
being able to detect when a new image
gets pushed
so let's give it another 30 seconds or
so and we should see those changes
get applied so right now we're still
using the old image because we still
have all those extra characters
but once we see this update we should
then be able to send a request and get
the updated code
all right so it ran so it looks like it
updated so it's stopping our container
give it a few more seconds to create a
brand new container
all right and so now it's good to go so
let's test this out hit send
and there we go
now if you haven't already done so go
ahead and delete that watchtower
container uh we're not going to use it
moving forward i just wanted to show you
guys how you could automate that last
step
so just do a docker rm watchtower f
now one of the things i want to talk to
you guys about is our current
workflow and that is you know whether
you're using watchtower to
do the pulling of the image and
restarting in the container or if you
mainly do it manually
doing it yourself by doing a docker
compose pull and then an up
at the end of the day we have to
recreate the container so we have to
tear down
our current container we have to build a
brand new container with a brand new
image
and then start that container and during
that window of tearing down and building
up
we are going to experience uh a network
outage essentially we are going to
experience
our application being down right our
app's going to be down
until that new container gets built so
we are going to experience loss
uh with our production traffic and
i was trying to see if there was a way
we could achieve
basically rolling updates with daca
compose so that we could somehow
do this upgrade process or push out new
changes to our production server without
experiencing any loss
and going through a whole bunch of stack
overflow responses
there were some hacks that we could put
together right we could really hack up
docker compose
to do a few things so that we can almost
achieve something that's similar to a
rolling update
um but ultimately you know these were
hacks
these were nothing more than hacks and
they were not recommended
to be run in a production network right
because remember docker compose
isn't meant for that docker compose is
not a container orchestrator
it is not meant to provide you a way to
implement rolling updates or anything
like that like at the core of docker
compose right remember
docker compose is just nothing more than
a file that maps out to
different docker run commands right
because a service is nothing more than a
container
which gets created with docker run so
this docker compose file
just gives us a way to basically write
down all of our docker run commands
within a yaml file and then when we do a
docker compose up it just runs all of
the docker commands for us so that we
don't need to actually type them out
ourselves
so it's not an orchestrator so what are
some options that we have
to help us achieve you know lossless
upgrades and
rolling updates well we can use one of
the popular
uh container orchestrators that we have
and one of those is kubernetes so that's
one of the purposes of kubernetes so
that's what we're going to do we're
going to cover kubernetes in the next
section
and i'm just kidding just kidding guys
there's no way we're going to cover
kubernetes in this next section i don't
want this video series
to end up being a 40-hour tutorial so
instead
what we're gonna do is we're going to
use a built-in
container orchestrator that comes with
docker and that is docker swarm
and i know some of you guys are
disappointed um because i know you guys
want to learn kubernetes
and kubernetes is the new kid on the
block but
the reason why i wanted to show you guys
how to do this with uh
docker swarm is because first of all we
already have at our disposal
it's very easy we don't really need to
spend too much time going over the
theory
and the main the main idea behind why
i'm even showing you guys how to do this
with docker swarm
is to just show you guys what is the
purpose of a container orchestrator
right because the idea behind this whole
video tutorial series
is not to show you how all of these
tools work
and all the ins and outs and all the
flags it's to show you how you put all
of these pieces together
why we need a container orchestrator and
what it ultimately helps us achieve
right so that's why i kind of walked you
guys through all of these steps instead
of just starting out with docker swarm
because
i wanted to show you why we need a
container orchestrator so in the next
section
we're going to get started with docker
swarm uh we're not going to spend too
much time going through the ins and outs
of docker swarm we're just going to get
something up and running
and just show how we can implement some
sort of rolling update so that we can
push out changes
to a production network without
experiencing any loss or at least
experiencing only minimal amounts of
loss
i want to quickly highlight some of the
differences between docker compose and
docker swarm
and we already discussed some of the
limitations with docker compose and that
is that it's ultimately not a container
orchestrator
so it can't handle some of the more
important life cycle
uh events when it comes to spinning up
and deleting containers and
being able to do rolling updates and
things like that that's something that
docker swarm can handle
right docker compose is a very simple
tool it's actually meant to only be a
development tool that we can use to kind
of spin up containers and then delete
them but it can't do much else
and it certainly can't do things like
rolling updates and another important
thing about docker compose is
uh we can only use it to deploy
containers onto one server
so if i wanted to be able to distribute
my express containers you know maybe
five or six of them
across multiple servers so that if one
goes down we'll have some redundancy
with the other service being able to
pick up the slack
i can't do that with docker compose
that's where docker swarm comes in
docker swarm is an orchestrator right so
there's more logic behind docker swarm
docker compose can only run just a bunch
of docker run commands right it's just a
bunch of docker run commands
that's listed out in a yaml format
docker swarm has logic has brains
it gives us the ability to you know not
only spin up containers
but we can distribute them across as
many servers as we want
so we've got 510 production servers we
can spread them out across all of our
servers
we can handle the update process so if
we need to
push a new image to our production
server dr schwarm can then
uh basically spin up new containers
update those containers and then only
once we verify those containers are up
and running
we can then delete the old containers so
it gives us
a little bit more flexibility when it
comes to our production
environment and giving us some more
tools that docker compose
doesn't provide us and when it comes to
docker swarm like i said
you know docker swarm gives us a
multi-node environment which means we
can use multiple servers
to deploy our applications we don't need
to run everything all on one server
and so each server within a docker swarm
is referred to as a node and we've got
two different kinds of nodes
got measure node we've got a worker node
i'm not going to go too much into the
details of it but just you know
you i think just based off of those
names you have an idea as to what each
one does but a
manager node handles all the brains
behind everything right
the manager node is the one that pushes
out tasks to the worker nodes and the
worker nodes
carry out those tasks so the control
plane is going to reside on the managed
nodes and the worker nodes just
run tasks that it receives and keep in
mind
a manager node can be both a manager
node and a worker node and i think
that's what the default configuration is
so
uh that is something to keep in mind but
in our in this video series we're just
going to have one server
so we're just going to use docker swarm
to spin up one
individual node that's both a manager
node and a worker node to deploy our
application
and you might be thinking well if we're
just using uh onenote is there
potentially any reason why we not we
don't just go for daca compose
well first of all you know things like
rolling updates those are things that we
can't do with docker compose
and docker compose ultimately is not a
production-ready tool it's a development
tool so you shouldn't be using it for
your production environment unless it's
for like some fun
little home project or things of that
nature
so let's get started with setting up
swarm in our production environment
and like i said before docker swarm
actually gets
shipped with docker so when you install
docker you already have dockers form at
your disposal
the only problem is it's disabled by
default if you do a docker
info it's going to let you know whether
swarm is uh enabled or not
and we can see here swarm is set to
inactive so
to enable swarm all we have to do is
docker
swarm init that's going to initialize
swarm
and we're going to get an error and it's
basically saying that
you know we've got multiple ip addresses
we have to tell what ip address we want
to use for swarm
so it looks like digitalocean gives us
two ip addresses
uh one on ethernet zero one on ethernet
one let's just grab the one with the
public
facing ip and then we just need to pass
that into the advertise
dash addr flag
let me copy my public ip
all right and so now it says swarm is
initialized and
it defaults us into being a manager and
keep in mind when you're a manager
you're also
a worker by default and if we wanted to
add
more nodes into the swarm
uh the it provides us two commands so
this command is going to
allow us to add a new node into our
swarm as a worker node
and then this command down here is going
to give us
is going to allow us to add a new node
into the swarm as a manager node
but like i said we're going to stick
with just one node for now just to keep
things simple
and you'll see that you know docker
swarm is very similar to just doing
regular docker commands like docker run
docker create and things like that so if
i do a docker
help you'll see all the commands that we
have so we can do docker create which is
going to create a container
we can do docker rm to delete a
container
you can do docker update to update the
configuration for a container
you got docker stop which is going to
stop a container well
docker's form isn't really any different
right except instead of working with
containers
it works with services and a service
remember is pretty much just a container
so you'll see that there's a lot of
similarity between docker containers
just running individual docker
containers and running
swarm services so if i do a docker
service so this is how you get access to
all of the swarm related commands
and i just do help you'll see the
options we have so we have docker
service create right very similar to a
docker create which creates a container
we have ls which is going to list out
all the services we can delete a service
and then a lot of the orchestration
takes place with the rollback so you can
you know revert changes
you can scale up the number of instances
for a service and then we can update
specific details about a service so
i just really wanted to highlight that
you know there's nothing really that
much different between docker swarm
and just running regular docker commands
and so we can do all the things we want
to do
by just running docker service commands
however that's a little tedious
just like running all of the docker run
commands it's hard to remember all the
necessary flags and things like that so
if you remember or you recall when we
wanted to kind of automate all of our
docker run commands
we just put all of our docker run
configurations into a compose file
and the nice part about docker swarm is
that we can do the same exact thing
we can put all of our configurations
within a compose file
and what's even nicer is that we get to
use all of the
we can use our compose files that we
already have so we can use
everything that we have already
pre-configured and we could just add in
a few extra fields that are swarm
related
so let's pull up the documentation to
see the specifics form-related configs
so if you go to the reference section
under docker compose and just search for
the deploy section this is going to give
us a lot of the options that are
specific to docker swarm uh it's going
to give us all the information that we
need
and so skip endpoint mode that doesn't
matter labels doesn't matter
placement doesn't matter here's the
first
flag or option that we can add to our
compose file that's a little bit
interesting which is
replicas so here the replicas defines
how many instances of a specific service
you want to
run so if i set replicas to six like in
this example for my node app
service it's going to give us six
containers so
as our uh application demand grows
we can just spin up more and more
containers by increasing the number of
replicas
right there's a resources section where
we can kind of constrain the resources
that each
you know container can use we're not
going to do much uh
regard with regarding that restart
policy this is going to determine you
know when and how we restart container
you know if it crashes should we restart
it
if solo if so how long should we wait so
let's add restart policy as well as
replicas uh to our configuration
so under our prod file because we only
want to run
compose sorry we only want to run swarm
within our prod environment we don't
actually want to run it in our
development environment because in our
development environment we can just use
docker compose that's perfectly okay
so let's go to our prod under node app
we'll just add a section called
deploy and then let's add
in well first of all let's add replicas
and let's set it to eight and then for
our restart policy
we can add a condition of any so we're
going to restart it for any reason it
goes down
and we can set a delay between each
restart attempt but i don't really care
about that
now this is where things get interesting
rollback config and update config
so let's go to the update config section
this is kind of what we're most
interested in because we're trying to
create
a way to update our application without
experiencing any loss
and so this section just tells you you
know how do we configures how the
service should be updated
so useful for configuring rolling
updates so this is exactly what we need
this is
kind of the real reason we wanted to go
to docker swarm
so here we have this flag called
parallelism so this just sets the number
of containers to update at a time so if
you have eight containers and we gotta
update the image of all eight
what it's gonna do is if we set
parallelism to two it's going to update
two containers
at a time so you know we can run two
and then if at once those two are up
we'll then move on to the next two
containers
and then the next two so uh you know
when two containers go down the other
six just pick up the slack until it
comes back online
the delay is a time to wait between
updating a group of containers
then we have a failure action so what
should we do if an update fails we can
either continue rollback pause
and the default looks like it's pause
maybe we want to do rollback if it fails
so that it automatically rolls back for
and then you can also set the order so
there's a few other properties but
let's just set up parallelism and delay
for now
we're going to set that to 2 and we'll
set the delay to be 15 seconds
and then there's a few other flags that
you can probably search for but that's
all we really need for docker
for docker swarm you can see how easy it
is to integrate it into your docker
compose workflow we just had to add a
couple of properties and we're good to
go
so we made a few changes uh to our
docker compose file so we have to
actually push these changes
to our production server so we have to
do a commit and get and then do a git
push so
i do a git add and then we'll do it
again commit
and then we'll do a git push
right then in our production server
i'm going to do a git pull
so now we have the updated docker
compose file
and so now let's actually deploy it so
first of all um
if we do a docker ps it looks like we
still have all of our containers that we
deployed using docker compose so let's
let me see if i can find that docker
compose command right here
up we'll just change that to down so we
can delete everything
all right so everything's down so now to
deploy
you know our application using docker
swarm
there's a command called docker
and then stack so docker stack is how we
actually use that
and let's do the dash dash help and see
the options we have and there's
something called deploy so
that's probably what we want so let's do
that
and let's see what options we have not
many options
but there is this compose file so we
have to pass in the name of the compose
file
and so just like we did when we did
docker compose we have to pass in both
of our compose files
but instead of using dash f we have to
use dash c in this case
and then let's do a dash dash help again
and
we want to do a that's about it actually
so we have to well actually we have to
give it a stack name
so a stack name is just a name of your
application right so
when we create this stack which is i
guess think of it as like
all of your services bundled together
what do you want to give it what do you
want to name it as i'm just going to
call it my app
let's deploy that and so you can see
it's creating all of our services so
actually creates a network just like
docker compose
and then it's going to create our four
different services
and some docker commands or some docker
swarm related commands you can do a
docker node
ls this is going to list out all of the
nodes within our docker swarm and so you
can see here
this is this specific node we only have
one node in this case
if you do docker stack ls it's going to
list out all of your stacks we just have
one stack
called myapp if we do a docker stack
and then let's do help
we can list out all the services in a
stack so let's do docker stack
and then services and then we call my
app
and it's going to list out the four
different services so you can see
the different uh images this is the
equivalent of doing just like a docker
ps
right so we see you know the container
name or the container id
the name it's given how many times it's
replicated so we only have one [ __ ]
container and then what image it's using
if you take a look at our node app
container we have eight of them so we
have eight
individual containers for that and we
can verify that by doing a docker ps
and you can see most of these are node
app containers
eight of them specifically if you want
to list out all of the services
across all stacks you could do docker
service ls however keep in mind we only
have one stack so we see the same exact
output as we saw before
all right now we can also list out tasks
right
and i guess i didn't really go over a
task but when it comes to
creating a new service updating a
service deleting a service
docker swarm generates a task and then
it pushes that task out to a worker node
so that the worker then can actually
perform that task
so if i do a docker service
sorry docker stack
ps and then we let's do dash dash help
and then we pass in the stack name it
looks like so doctor psn so this is
going to list out all of the
tasks for my stack so it's going to be
called my app
and you can see all of the tasks that i
created
all right and so you could see a task
out generated for each one of these
containers so it looks like it's to
provision
uh all of our containers
all right so now let's go ahead and make
a change to our application and see if
we can update
our production server with those changes
but with a
rolling update methodology using docker
swarm so that
we experience minimal to no loss
and so if i just first of all actually
let's just double check to make sure our
application still works
and so here we got a response and we can
see it says hi there
let's go back to our code and i'm going
to add some more exclamation points
and a few other things let's save that
in this case we want to do a build for
our node app so we build a brand new
image with those changes
and then we want to do a push of our
node app
so we push it to docker hub
all right and so now let's go to our
production server
and i'm just going to keep hitting the
what happened there
let's find that docker stack deploy
command so let's see if we just run this
again
if it's able to pick up those changes
and so it looks like it's updating our
services so let's see
docker stack ps
node app sorry not node app my
app it's going to list out all of our
tasks
and look at what's happening here it
looks like we shut down
two of our containers right and that's
because of our parallelism right
so if we go to dockercompose.yaml
actually.prod.yml you can see we should
only update two at a time
and then after it's been updated we'll
wait 15 seconds and then we'll wait for
the next two
so if i take a look at this and run this
again to see all of our tasks
you can see we now have what one oh
sorry one
two three four so two more of them got
shut down and two new ones were created
so let's then run this again
and we should see two more
and so there's just a couple more of our
original eight containers that need to
get updated so you can see it's just
doing two at a time
and while it's updating right now if i
send it right you can see
it's been updated for some of them let
me see if i can hit one of them right
and so i can hit one of them that hasn't
been updated
but it looks like most of them have been
updated oh it looks like we
received an error um like i said even
with
a orchestrator doesn't guarantee that we
won't have
no downtime but you can see this greatly
minimized it
and then let's try this again
and we can see that for each one of our
eight
containers we had a previous task where
we shut it down and then we have the new
one
that we're running and if i push these
changes out again so if i do this whole
process one more time delete this
we'll do the same two things we'll do a
build
and then we'll do a push
and then we can do a stack deploy we
don't need to pass in any other
arguments
it'll check with docker hub to pull the
latest image
and so now if i do a ps my app um you
can see that
there's two of them that have been shut
down so uh it's gonna do two at a time
like i said and let's just
run this again so you can see i get the
exclamation still for
a lot of the requests some of them i
don't though because like i said two of
those containers have already been
changed and then by now it's probably
four
and eventually if i just keep doing this
after about it's probably going to take
about a minute
but let's run this again
and you can see most of them have
already been changed
all right so it looks like all of our
containers have been updated we can
verify that by just running this again
and you should see that each one should
be up in a running state after the
previous one got shut down
and so that's pretty much all i have for
you guys for this video series
hopefully you guys have a better
understanding of how docker works and
how we can
develop a node and express applications
using docker and how we can move from a
development environment to a production
environment and i really did want to
emphasize
a lot of the challenges that you face
when going from development to
production because
docker it was created to simplify that
process but even with docker there's
still going to be plenty of challenges
and so now that you guys have a basic
understanding of how all of this works
you know you can kind of take some of
the ideas that i've taught you and kind
of tweak it so that you can build your
own
uh development to production workflow
obviously in this video
i didn't cover anything with regards to
you know building out like a ci cd
pipeline
uh that would be the logical next step
so i'll probably make a
video series showing you how we can
actually build a full ci cd pipeline for
a docker based application
but i think this is a good starting
point for people that just want to get a
little bit more familiar
with you know deploying apps and as well
as getting familiar just with docker in
general